This is Jocko podcast number one
oh seven with Echo Charles and me,
Jocko Willink. Good
Evening Echo. Good evening.
So the battle of I drang
valley was over for now and
okay,
we just spent two podcasts talking
about it and one of the things that you
forget sometimes about the military
is that the machine rolls on.
Mm hmm. The machine rolls on.
There's a work to do and it doesn't.
It doesn't matter what you've been through
or what you experienced or how many
men or friends or leaders you lost.
The machine is going to roll on.
There's still work to do.
At least it's going to try and roll on.
And that means normal things
are gonna continue to happen,
meaning that people are
going to get reassigned,
people are going to leave the army,
people are going to retire.
People are going to transfer. You
don't stay together. You don't.
You don't stay together with these
guys that you just went through.
Whatever you went through with.
And as much as you might feel like
a family with that group of guys,
you're not going to get treated
like a family in the military.
It's the machine is going to roll on and
with that mind to close out the book,
we were soldiers once and young that
again was covering podcast one oh five and
one oh six I'm going to read one more
passage from that book and here we go back
to the book every morning during those
final bittersweet days of my command of
the first battalion,
Seventh Cavalry Sergeant Major Plumley
would appear with a group of men bound
for the airfield and the plane that
would take them home for discharge
specialist for Pat Selleck
of the recon platoon,
says Colonel Moore shook our hands
and said thank you and go back home.
I was the second or third guy he
spoke to and he had tears in his eyes.
I remember what he said.
I see that you're married,
you have a wedding ring on.
Just go home,
pick up the pieces and start
your life all over again.
And basically that's what I did.
I came home to a wonderful wife,
tried to readjust,
did a decent job at it.
I did what Colonel Morris said.
I tried to put the war behind me.
I served, I did my job. I came home.
I didn't ask for anything,
no fanfare, no parades.
I went back to work back
to school and did my best.
He might be a general,
but he still Colonel Moore to me.
Okay.
If it wasn't for him and all
his knowledge and training,
I don't think any of us would
have survived the, I drank valley
on Tuesday,
November 23rd the day came for me to
turn over command for the change of
command. I requested a full battalion
formation with officer's front and center.
The division band trooping the line
honors to the reviewing officer and colors
and then pass in review.
Reminiscent of our weekly retreat
parades back at Fort Benning.
I requested that captain did, Directs
Bravo Company, Second Battalion,
Seventh Cavalry and lieutenant systems,
platoon of Alpha company,
second of the seventh be included in
the per tape parade of First Battalion
Seventh Cavalry in token to the fact
that they fought bravely alongside us in
the battle at X-ray.
Yeah,
and so it was
the band played colonel bogey and the
Washington Post March and Gary Owen.
Yeah.
General Canard pinned on my eagles and
I spoke briefly and with deep emotion.
Okay.
SPEC for Ray Turner of Alpha Company.
First Battalion said we stood in formation
with some units hardly having enough
men to form up.
Okay.
Colonel Hal Moore spoke
to us and he cried.
Okay.
At that moment, he could have
let us back into the, I drag.
Yeah.
We were soldiers.
We were fighting men and those of us
who were left had the utmost love and
respect for our kernel
and for one another.
Okay.
As I reflect on those three days in
November, I remember many heroes,
but no cowards.
Yeah.
I learned what value life really had.
We all lost friends,
but the bravery they
showed on the battlefield,
we'll live forever.
Well,
we have tried here
two
remember and display
and spread the word on some
of that bravery that were
shown on the battlefields
so that it does live on.
And I think that is the least we can do.
Yeah.
That and learn,
try and learn.
We must always try and learn and we can
certainly learn from a man that had been
through so much and was so
respected and revered by his men.
And so today we're going
to delve into another book.
Okay.
And this one is actually by General Hal
Moore and Co written by another army
vet,
a younger army vet,
another off author Mike Gornia.
And the book is called
how more on leadership.
And it's just that it's principles and
faults about leadership that how more
learned.
Okay.
And then implemented throughout
his life and his career. And again,
if you haven't listened to podcasts,
one oh five and one oh six yet,
go back and listen to those podcasts first
because that'll give you some context
as to what general more live through and
why we should pay attention to what he
has to say.
So again,
the book is how more on leadership.
Okay.
The subtitle is a winning
when outgunned and outmanned
kicks off in the prologue, it says all
of one's life is a learning experience.
I learned a lot of lessons along the way.
I'm still learning.
These are values, principles, lessons
I've learned, mistakes, successes,
and my thoughts on
leadership from watching,
studying and reading about
leaders in action, good leaders,
mediocre leaders,
and bad leaders.
So he wrote this book.
This book only came out,
I actually have to check.
It came out very came out in 2017
so this book is at the end of,
of how Mora's life.
And here we go.
We're gonna jump right into
some of these principles.
He starts off with four basic principles
of leadership. Principle number one,
three strikes. And you're not
out in the game of baseball,
three strikes and you're out not.
So in the game of life,
three strikes and you're not out.
Okay.
There are two things a leader can do.
He can either contaminate his environment
and his people with his attitude and
actions, or he can inspire
confidence. Good point.
Hmm. There's always another
way in life, right? Sure.
Three strikes for strikes.
You can keep swinging.
There's no umpire to call you out.
Back to the book. He must have,
have and display the will to
prevail by his actions, his words,
his tone of voice, his appearance,
his demeanor, his countenance,
and the look in his eyes.
He must never give off any hint or
evidence that he is uncertain about a
positive outcome.
Yeah.
So that's something that, you
know, we saw an action in the book.
We were soldiers once and
young when you know, Rick,
we're scroller comes up and says, where
are they at? Good. Oh, big. Bring it.
They got tonight.
Just even though inside he
admitted he was worried. Yeah. But,
and then you hear the reactions of
the other guys. They were saying, wow,
that's cool. At least this guys in the
game, look, I'm, I'm game. If he's game,
let's go.
Do you think that that could elicit
some sort of a blow back in? Definitely.
It definitely. In fact, I have my note
there. You wanna see my note right there.
Says, can you read that? It says really,
cause it's one of those things for sure.
You're right. Eight, if you roll in and
you're getting smashed and you show,
you can, you can seem oblivious to
reality. Yeah, yeah, yeah, exactly.
He addresses that. Standby.
Here we go. Back to the book.
It struck me early in my reading
in school and later in life,
that is a common theme running through
books and stories about great leaders.
Was there positive outlook,
positive mental attitude,
PMA for all those bad
brains fans out there.
They were aware of the pitfalls.
They were. This is the your point.
They were aware of the
pitfalls and negatives,
but they refuse to fret and worry
about them. So there you go.
No, we're not talking like, oh
this isn't happening over there.
Like remember Baghdad. Bob, are
you old enough to remember that?
But I think you mentioned Baghdad.
Bob Wall tanks were just while the Iraqi
army was getting obliterated in the
first Gulf War. He was sitting there
going, Oh yes, we've had many victories.
You know, he just completely oblivious
to what was happening in, and there's,
I think there was literally like bombs
going off in the background. Yeah,
Baghdad. Bob. Okay, here we go.
Back to the principle number two.
There's always one more thing you can
do to influence any situation in your
favor.
And after that there's one more thing.
And after that one more thing.
The one more things you do,
the more one more things you do,
the better your chances are for achieving
success in any situation. Elite.
This is interesting.
A leader must create time to detach
himself mentally and ask one of my,
what am I doing that I should not be doing
and what am I not doing that I should
be doing to influence the
situation in my favor?
So he's talking about attachment.
I agree with them clearly.
That's a good,
it's good to have those like specific
things to ask yourself when you detach.
You know how like I'd always ask yourself
like, okay, what do we have here?
But even that, that's like a broad
question broad, right? Yeah. That's like,
that's way better. That's
good. Yeah. If you think about,
if you think about your life and you've,
you were constantly saying like, what,
what, what should I be doing right
now and what should I not be?
We're all doing things that we should not
be doing, right? Well not me, but yeah,
man. Oh, you're, you're just
perfect. Perfect. So we're
all doing things that we, we,
we know we shouldn't be doing and we're
all know that there's things that we
should be doing that
we're not so detached.
Look at yourself. Do an assessment. Yeah.
I'm sure that's like a goldmine of things
you can change right there for sure.
It's two questions for sure.
Here's a,
here he says a leader is
paid to do three things,
get the job done and get it done. Well,
plan ahead. Be Proactive, not reactive,
exercise, good sound judgment,
and doing all of the above
to get the job done.
The leader must have a clearly defined
mission along with specific goals and
objectives.
So there you go.
Brandon pick worth hit me up.
Sure.
Because the last podcast I was talking
about goals and he had sent me a text
about
getting belt.
I think it was about getting belt in
Jujitsu and I think that's what it was.
But anyways,
he was basically calling me a hypocrite
because, you know, my, my, my thing is
like, hey, you trained to get better.
You don't train because you want this
thing, right. You train because you,
you have, uh, uh, I should see, it's not
that, it's not that there's no goal there,
but your goal is different.
Your goal isn't a material item of cloth.
Your goal is to get better at Jujitsu.
Brandon, yeah, you're on lockdown.
You want to hear a very seemingly far
fetched analogy to that. But it's not.
The other night I was,
uh,
making arts and crafts. Uh,
we went down with Presley.
You just chilling out
doing some paper per say.
So, so, uh, why did she do shit?
She will basically, I said a joke and
then she laughed at and I, no, no,
she said a joke and then I
laughed. And then she, so she said,
I'm gonna I'm gonna say this
joke again and laugh again.
Just like you did before. Yeah.
So am I. So I thought about that.
Of course I did it,
but weak
story of my life right there.
But um, so she says it,
I do it right. And then I'm thinking
like, isn't that interesting?
She got the laugh and that was a big
payoff. It, here's the thing, in a way,
she shouldn't be focusing on the last,
he should be focusing
on saying funny jokes.
The laugh just for, where'd you take it?
Easy. I didn't tell her that didn't score,
but you see what I'm saying?
No, same thing. Jujitsu.
You focus on getting better at Jujitsu.
The belt will come as
kind of like a result,
a little byproduct if you
will dislike the laughs.
So you know when you're telling jokes,
go for the funniness. Not for the laugh,
the laugh or I'll talk to Presley,
I'll pull her aside.
I have a little chat with her. Well maybe
you know Brandon pick worth, you know,
maybe he'd, you know, find
that very enlightening.
Just see tighten him
up. He did. By the way,
he did do his hundred burpees and
sub 10 minutes. He actually got it.
I forget what his time was. Yeah, I never,
I never went back there to do that man.
You did it easily then you do these.
They did it.
It depends on what you mean by easily.
You did it or not did it.
I did it with
did you have minutes to spare?
I had a minute to spare
if I remember correctly.
Had One minute to spare and I knew that
at like the last coasted crews kind.
I coasted into the finish line week. It
was still Kinda, I was sore the next day.
I was actually, sorry Brandon one
his video. He did good burpees.
I'll give him that much credit. Better
burpees than my normal burpees for sure.
Yeah. Like is burpees look,
they look clean. So mine,
they didn't merit like 12 minutes
when he got that down. Yeah. Yeah.
If you would have saw my burpees
and said, hey, those aren't full,
all of those aren't full burpees. I
would not be surprised. Put it that way.
Just do. Okay. All right.
Going back to the book,
the smart leader should
always think through the what
ifs and have a plan on how
to handle them before they occur.
Times so spent is never wasted.
Things do not always go as planned.
So again,
he talks a bunch about planning and he's
like, got things don't go as planned.
And we all have to remember that the
smart leader must also be mindful of as
organization's constraints
and center of gravity.
There can be one or several constraints
that inhibits getting the job done.
And I think we all kind of understands
that and he says that the constraints
must accurately be defined.
But the center of gravity idea was,
it was a little bit more interesting
to me. Here we go to the book.
The center of gravity is the principal
thing or activity that must be in balance
or under control for an organization to
operate is the organization's source of
strength. In addition to understanding
your own center of gravity to protect it,
you must recognize and attack
your enemies or competitors,
center of gravity to defeat them.
In that battle in Vietnam,
my center of gravity was the landing zone.
So he's talking about the,
I drank valley and the new that and lock
that thing down and fought hard for it.
Dean, I was training with Dean,
I dunno, a few months ago,
and then he was teaching a class and
one thing you said that was really
interesting and really smart
about Jujitsu is he's like,
Hey, when you're on the ground,
you can't have your balance attack.
Meaning if you're the on the bottom,
you can't have your belt, your audio,
you're going down there. So you have to
mess with the person's balance on top.
He's like, they can't mess with your
balance cause you're already down there.
You need to mess with their balance.
Yeah, good point, Huh? Yeah, exactly.
It's one of those things. Yeah,
there's a lot. There's a lot to that.
There's a lot to that.
Interestingly, it's like val, you're,
cause you're talking about like a
really deep fundamental concept.
One thing for sure. And a lot of times
we don't learn all of them. You know,
we enjoyed it too and
obviously in life too,
but we don't learn all
the fundamental concepts.
So even you can go through life
and be successful, you know,
varying levels and then get introduced
to one fundamental concept that'll just
like, Dang. And this is something that,
you know, I know we all know if you did,
you did too.
You know that if you're on the bottom,
you've got a suite to get on top of, you
know, you, you know that. But what he was,
he wasn't even saying sweep.
Yeah. He was saying you have to,
you have to attack their balance.
Yeah.
Cause you can't have your balance tact
cause you're on the ground already.
You attack their balance and it's
just going to open things up.
He wasn't talking. You're gonna
sweep every time. No you're not.
You're going to get the unlock though.
You're going to get a position change
going to get rolled into a heal hook.
Right. But it's interesting when
he talks it like when, when,
how more general more here is talking
about not only do you have to know your
center of gravity, you've got to know
your opponent, center of gravity.
So that's what you attack.
Which is interesting because people
would most heavily defend their center of
gravity,
you would think.
And therefore it would be counter to
the Sun Tzu principle of don't attack to
heavily guarded area but
or heavily defended area.
But
you got to find a way to get
through to their center of gravity.
Otherwise you're not gonna put them
off balance. You're not going to win.
Like that's one of the goals, you know
is the attack that cause some people,
I mean even cause Dean tour totally
clarified the concept for you. Yeah.
Where it's like this is going on in the
game and you know maybe that maybe in
certain circumstances it's intuitive.
Like okay I'm going to tack this guy's
balanced because specifically I'm going
for a specific suite or whatever.
Maybe it'll come in and out of your mind,
but if you have that clear in your mind
that that's part of this whole game that
we're playing and, and go
back to the sunsuit. Well,
just because this is me figuring out
right now is just because you're attacking
their center of gravity doesn't mean
you have to do a frontal assault on,
you should still flanking
exactly what I mean. Yeah.
But now at the end of the day, now
that's part of my goal. You know,
my goal isn't just to kill everyone
or whatever. It's like, okay,
we're going to attack this,
this center of gravity specifically
because that'll open up with it, you know,
and everything else that comes with
it. Yeah. But it's clarified now it is
back to the book while
getting the job done,
the leader must plan ahead and create
the future. He must be proactive,
not reactive. Truly great leaders have
acuity, our perceptive, aggressive,
enthusiastic,
concede trends,
analyze them carefully and correctly,
have a vision, have confidence in it,
and can inspire and motivate himself
and his people to make it happen.
That's a big laundry list of
things for a leader to be doing.
Hmm.
That's why leaders,
that's why leadership is hard job.
Thinking about all those
things I just rattled off.
He must have a positive attitude and must
hate the word no. He must have smart,
well trained people to
run day to day activities.
He must check up on them and make sure
the job is getting done while he stacks
the deck for future success. So you can
see right now he's not micromanaging.
He's getting people that can do the
job and then he's looking forward.
Principle number three,
when nothing is wrong,
there's nothing wrong except
there's nothing wrong.
That's when a leader has to be most alert.
Complacency
leaders are paid to
create order out of chaos.
History is replete with examples of
leaders who failed because they became too
complacent in the days and months
leading up to Pearl Harbor,
American military leaders,
we're confident that the Japanese
could never strike American soil.
Our naval intelligence said that Pearl
Harbor was too far out of reach for a
Japanese naval taskforce. They were also
convinced the harbor was too shallow.
For a torpedo attack.
Instead of prioritizing the threat
from an aggressive naval enemy,
the Army Air Corps commander at wheeler
and Hickam fields put a higher priority
on the threat from spies and saboteurs.
They grouped the planes together at
the air field to make them easier for
walking centuries to guard on foot patrol.
But when the Japanese bombers arrived
on December 7th the clustered American
planes became Turkey shoot
targets. Didn't know that. Hmm.
Didn't know that wrong threat assessment.
And now you're doing something that's
actually gonna help your enemies real
attack. But it's complacency. Hmm.
Pin principle number four,
trust your instincts.
Instincts are the product
of one's personality,
experience reading and education.
That's,
that's interesting, right?
He puts reading in there.
You're actually getting experience from
reading a new house said that General
Mattis, General Mattis, he reads,
I think he has a personal book
collection of like 5,000 or 7,000 books.
Personal Book Collection. Okay.
That was good. And he said he,
that's to prevent him from being
surprised because if you know history,
you know the future.
Hmm.
But that's a great definition of what
instinct is. Cause people think instinct.
Is this something that's some
mysterious thing, right? But no,
it's your personality, experience,
reading and education. Yeah.
As far as the context, he's
putting it in. I mean, instinct,
obviously it's clearly
defined as something else.
What is it clearly defined as?
Say I knew, oh no, no, no. You know how
like animals have instincts to, oh yeah,
we have instincts to procreate, like
all this stuff like that. I mean,
obviously he's talking about a specific
concept yet he's not talking about the
instinct to procreate. No, no, no,
no. Something else. But I'm saying,
you know what I mean? It's
not there as mystical. Yes.
His definition is not mystical.
Yeah. It's like, Hey, read, learn,
experience and then, yeah. So
you know, like how, um, you know,
your gut feeling kind
of thing. Yeah. So yeah.
It's to me like if you don't
have any experience in any, uh,
like you're not reading
nothing and you don't have any,
you're not going to have many
gut instincts. No. You will.
You'll still be way off.
Yeah. Yeah. I was gonna be funny,
I was talking about talking about
this with someone when, uh,
sometimes like with an injury,
let's say you have an injury and
you think, I'll just do this,
but what you're is actually completely
wrong. Yeah. Yeah. That
happens to me. Sometimes I'll
have an injury and I'll say,
you know what? I'll just keep
stretching it. It hurts a little bit,
but it'll be okay. I think that's helping
it. And I'm just wrong. Just wrong. Yeah.
And the,
so let's say you were,
you did that over and over and over and
over and over and over and over again,
which you probably have, but I'm
saying normal person, you do it over,
then the instincts will
kind of recalibrate itself.
Yeah. Because eventually you go,
hey, this doesn't work. Yeah. Hey,
do you mobilize that broken wing
or whatever? Yeah, exactly. Check.
Just like,
if you don't know,
did you tune when you get into a fight
with someone who does need you to say
you're going to do your instincts that
you know, which is nothing, by the way,
and your instincts are gonna be completely
wrong. Completely wrong. But you dude,
this guy off me. Yeah, exactly.
Or I'll power out of this.
Oh, you know, I'll go off
per hard. That's a great example. Yeah,
and then when you learn did you
to recalibrate your instincts now,
now your instincts are good and proper
unless you get one of these tricky guys
who knows your instincts.
So he's going to base his instincts off
a year and to see what I'm saying. Yeah.
Now we're getting in strategy
though. That's true. All right.
Back to the book.
It's a nice talking about instinct.
It's a kind of sixth sense when seconds
count instincts and decisiveness come
into play in quick developing situations,
the leader must act fast in park
confidence to all around him.
Must not second guessed the decision,
make it happen in the process.
He cannot stand around slack jawed
when he's hit with the unexpected,
he must face up to the facts
and deal with them and move on.
When my head tells me to do one thing
and my gut tells me to do another,
I will always go with my
gut. Why? Because my gut,
because my gut as I've
learned is rarely wrong.
Now that's, that's a bold
statement right there. Yeah.
You got to my,
if my instincts are telling me one thing
and my brain is telling me something
else that is, to me, that's the
time to reassess what's going on.
Cause I've got some conflicting things
happening going because I'm pretty
logical in thinking through things.
And if that is getting completely
countered by just some emotional feeling,
which kind of, that's what an instinct
is, right? That's, that can be my name. B,
it can be emotional. Right. So you
gotta watch out for that. Yeah.
It seems like in an emotion or a situation
predicated on emotion strongly like
a, I dunno, a relationship with
somebody. I'm just going to go with my,
this case met your gut. Your
heart to go with my gut. Yeah.
You're wrong. No, no, no.
Yeah. You're probably wrong on now. And
I'll think about it. Commodity logic,
logical side, back to the book
instinct as a kind of caution light,
an early warning or a gut feeling which
can on occasion result in a far better
decision than one based
on a logical process.
One rule of thumb I learned more than 60
years ago at west point is if there's a
doubt in your mind,
there's no doubt at all.
Okay.
In other words, if you know in your heart
that an action is wrong, don't do it.
One of my sons calls this
the rule of doubts above all,
never tried to fake out,
deceive or fool the people under you.
Not only is it wrong but the troops
can smell bs from miles away.
Hmm.
See that starts to make more sense.
If it's something that's wrong
then it makes a lot of sense,
but it makes a lot of
sense rather than right.
The the way I hurt would
hear this and the teams,
I didn't need to know
it came from west point,
but they'd say if there is a
doubt than there is no doubt,
which I guess is the same thing,
which is this shorter.
If there is a doubt than there
is no doubt and that means what?
Like if meaning any doubt, then that means
there's no doubt that it's wrong. Yes,
yes. Or if you're saying, wait, I don't
know if this is the right thing to do,
it's probably not. Okay. Probably not.
Instincts
like when ducks fly south for the winter,
weight is it's north or south,
they fly south for the winter warmer.
That's an instinct,
but I don't know what that is. Is that
an instinct? Yeah. Cool. Straight up.
Just like,
like if your baby like suckling,
you know so you can feed.
That's instinct.
Interesting. Let's see. Back to the book.
Back to the book of the discipline that
makes an effective leader begins in the
home. In most cases learning comes
through observation and experience.
It is through the parents and or legal
guardians where we first begin to
understand right from wrong and success
or failure in having guidelines and
expectations set before me as a young
boy having to toe the line was the
standard of every day.
While I remember my mother and father
requiring discipline and proper conduct,
there was an equal balance of
love. Fondant, fishing, reading,
religion and daydreaming.
Yes. Daydreaming,
discipline. Cool. Daydreaming.
Makes Sense. But you don't automatically
associate that with discipline.
No, you don't. You don't.
But if you follow your
daydreams all the time,
then you won't end up with anything. So
you have to have them both. Yeah. Yeah.
Next one. No job is ever
beneath you in whatever you do,
do it to the best of your abilities.
Next, the best leaders try
the best leaders strive to
create a family environment
within their organization. A good
leader aims to his subordinates feel
that they are valued members of a team.
The same loyalty that goes up the chain
of command must also go down the chain
of command and across the
network of subordinates.
Yeah,
and and by the way, of course, as
always, I'm not reading this whole book.
There's all kinds of better detail in
the book itself and explanations and I'm
hitting the the wave tops as
they say. Sure. That's good.
I like this one a little bit.
The first person you have to
lead and discipline is yourself.
Okay,
good versus poor choices.
Make all the difference in the world.
Hmm.
Concur. Back to the book. To be a leader,
you must be willing to
be a lifelong learner.
The leaders who fail are those who think
they know everything or that they have
nothing left to learn.
They resent having to learn something
new or adapt to a new situation.
Got To be humble.
Hey, this is interesting. I like
to do a lot of listening that way.
I pick up a lot of good ideas. Many
from subordinates. When you listen,
you know twice as much as the other guy,
what he knows and what you know.
Just also whenever the boss talked,
I not only listened but I took notes.
I still carry three by five cards
today, so that's, that's a great one.
If you let someone else talk,
I was doing a security detail.
He and I rack my first
appointment over there and I,
and we picked up a high high ranking
officer and we were the security detail
form and he was picking up some
subordinate officers along the way.
And it was so interesting how
this high ranking officer,
depending on who got in the vehicle,
because we met with multiple
different subordinate officers of his,
and it was American guy. What's that?
Oh yeah. These are all Americans,
all Americans. But the senior officer, he,
he would barely say anything and the
guys would get in and you can hear them,
you know, at first they sort of listen
for a minute and they couldn't handle it.
So they just start
talking and they tell us,
they tell the boss everything
is a great technique.
You just sit there quietly and you, these
people are spilling their guts. Yeah.
Isn't that in negotiation?
For sure. For sure. Yeah.
Where you just don't see anything.
You just need to be like, well yeah.
And it can make people uncomfortable.
Yeah.
But that's a great way of looking at it.
And when you talk you're,
and that same thing
happens in any situation.
I've said it before on this podcast. The
more you talk, the less people listen,
Huh? Yeah. Just the way it is. Yeah.
He had a kind of a, some challenges
getting into West Point and oh,
he did get in and he had a couple of
lessons learned from that and never say no
to yourself when you need to
ask for something, make the
other guy say no. That's,
that's, that's a good point, right?
Like I'm not just going to say I'll
echo would never say yes to this,
so I'm just going to knock and ask
him. No, I'm going to ask him echo,
can you make a couple more videos?
Worst thing you can do is say no,
which is likely, I forget if I
read this or listening to it,
but there's two kinds of askers
people who ask for stuff, right?
There's two kinds.
One Who thinks like that where it's
like the worst they can say is no.
Somebody last or the second
kind who is like, he, you know,
he might say no, but I, you
know how like some people,
I don't know if you're like
this, maybe you are, I dunno,
but some people they're uncomfortable
when to like saying no to someone.
Like it's like you're the bad
guy, you know, kind of like, Hey,
can you retweet this charity
or something like that.
And then if you say no,
you're the bad guy.
And that's an extreme example of course.
But the people are like that.
But some people there, if they're,
I forget the name of the ask or,
but if you're the kind of ask her that's
like, oh, the worst they can say no.
If you're that kind of
person and someone asks you,
you have no usually have
no problem saying no.
But if you're the other
kind where it's like, Dang,
now he put me in a
position to be the bad guy.
They're way less likely to ask for stuff
because they don't want to feel that
way. They don't want to put that person
in that position. So it's like, yeah,
the worst thing they can say no,
but I don't want to put him
in that position because
he's going to feel like how
I would test your skin.
There's like two kinds of people,
but it's weird when you get the
clash of the kind of person,
let's say I'm the kind of person who I
don't want to put you in the position to
say no. So I kind of, I'll be real
shy to ask, but you're the opposite.
You're going to be asking me for
stuff and I'm going to be like,
I won't answer you. I'll be
bothered by if you, you know,
first few days and be like, man, I
can't believe he's asking me to do this.
You know, I can't believe he's
asking me to give me shit. Yeah, no,
but in my mind, if I say no, now I'm
the bad guy and now you're in my mind,
you're at home sitting, can't believe
like, he won't do this for me or you know,
you go through all this
stuff, but um, yeah,
that's when you get that class
tormenting living in your head.
I'm like, no, next question. See.
But then even when you say like, no,
like text message fully
with text messages,
you know how you'll do
you say to real life,
but at least I can see the look on your
face. Like you're kind of half joking.
I see it and all this stuff. But in
text message you say, no period. Right?
That's it. So I'm like, no, chocolate
anatomy just mad at me for something.
And he's like, he wouldn't have said
it like that, you know? But so yeah,
you make it really hard and man,
people read into a lot of stuff then
that's obviously you have to read it into
some stuff to figure out what's going on.
Most people go crazy with that.
Are you even married? Right?
You got to read into everything.
Every little thing you got to eat into.
Hey,
you got to know. All right,
back to the book. Never quit.
Obvious. Next one of find a way
to turn every minus into a plus.
Good.
There is a solution to every problem.
Some are more complex than others.
There's always a way, uh,
while he was at West Point,
he
okay,
learned about toxic leadership and here
we go. They were, they were putting, um,
under the command or they're
putting the squads and here we go.
Each squad had two different squad
leaders one month with each. I've never,
never forgotten those two men. The first
one was arrogant, was an, was an arrogant,
sadistic person who
screamed and yelled at us,
made us do unmerciful physical exercises.
Apparently with the goal of driving
the week to quit the academy,
I despise that man. A leader should never
be arrogant, spiteful, condescending,
or engage in gossip.
To the contrary,
he should always act with humility and
treat his subordinates with respect and
dignity as a leader.
Your words and action to have greater
impact on your subordinates and you
realize,
thus choose your words carefully.
Avoid Sarcasm and flippancy.
Do not insult or take digs at
anyone's intelligence. Remember,
everyone processes information
differently and at different speeds.
Don't automatically assume that someone
is stupid or indifferent because they
haven't mastered a particular task yet.
Okay.
That stuff is so important.
This is something that I screw
up because, you know, being an s,
growing up in a seal platoon, everyone's
always like picking on each other. Uh,
what's that called? Verbally sparring
and cutting each other down, you know?
And that's just the way it is.
And I still have that in me.
Like the, I still have that in me, Hailey.
I don't know. Do I not
do that too? So what,
but I can do that sometimes
when I know I should, I'm like,
I'll do it to my kids sometimes
will do to my wife sometimes.
And sometimes I don't realize it
until afterwards. And the thing is
in my mind, I'm kidding. Yeah. It's
all good. Like I have no ill will,
but you know, you can't do that. Yeah.
So that's one I need to always be careful
of because I have a tendency to treat
other people like their e fives
and a seal platoon with me.
And that's not always good.
Yeah. Especially the wipe thing.
You mentioned that before the late, yeah.
Oh, I said it, this was the other day,
January 1st right.
First day of the new gear.
And I forget what my wife did.
Oh yeah.
I forgot what she did, but I was
like, oh, what a loser. Right? Yeah.
And here's the thing, I've said
that plenty of times and you know,
whatever to her, and she said it
to me, whatever, but they day,
but either way it was cut.
It's not like with you if I said that or
so, or something like that or whatever.
There would be a consistent reaction.
I hundred percent consent.
Right. Where you'd be
like, yeah, it's obviously,
I don't really think you're a loser.
Right.
The fact I said it is part
of verbal smart, whatever.
That's a consistent kind of
interpretation. You sheets. Yeah. And um,
but so she said back, she's like, oh,
first insult of the new year, kind of
like, sure. That was her joke back, right.
Like, you know, the first
thing they'd be here until
still a little like,
and what I interpreted
that or read into it, um,
is that Dang,
like,
it didn't take you much time to start
messing with me like that. You know? Like,
it's like,
oh, that's, that's what
she said. Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I think I was correct. I
felt it immediately and I
was like, Dang, I got to,
you got to be careful with that pen stuff.
If I said that to my brother,
you wouldn't carry.
This continues back to the book.
Contrary to popular belief,
yelling and yelling at and berating your
subordinates will not make them move
faster, nor will inspire
their loyalty. In fact,
it may encourage them to
begin plotting your demise.
Many years from now, your subordinates
will not remember what deadlines were met,
what sales were closed,
what products were shipped,
or what training schedules were executed.
What they remember is how you,
the leader treated them.
Whether you inspired a climate of trust
and dignity or ruled through fear,
metrics and intimidation.
It's interesting
and again, that's, that's
something that I don't do.
Like I might take jabs at people in
a fun way that sometimes are not as
interpreted as fun as I want them to,
but they don't yell at people.
I don't berate them. Uh, don't do anything
like that and do this is 100% right.
When you see people like
that, it's not good. And I,
when I started on this work working
with civilians, I think they actually,
people actually thought I was going to
come and yell and scream. Yeah. You know?
And I'd be like, no, I laugh.
And I used to be like a leaf when
we worked together for 18 months.
How many times did I raise my voice at
you? And He'd be like, zero. And we read,
sometimes you make the audience
guests, you know, or whatever.
And Lafe always cracks the joke of like,
there's a lot of times he wanted to
yell at me, but you know, we, you know,
like that doesn't work.
Yeah.
That is interesting how people think
that you're going to do that. I know.
Uh, maybe be, maybe
that's good. Maybe. Yeah,
maybe that's kind of part of the whole
thing. The whole picture, you know?
Why did they think that?
Maybe because you yell and scream at
other situations. I don't though. Well,
I have a few videos of you yelling and
screaming, yelling and screaming, Ward,
I don't know.
Stuff.
You get into other stuff. You don't
never yell and scream at someone.
Oh you mean like, I'm like, oh okay.
Well that's a little bit, yeah.
If I'm raising my voice is
being a bit more poignant.
Escalated. Yeah. Escalated.
That's not screaming though. Yeah.
So that's not yelling and
screaming at someone, you know. No.
So maybe they just like fuel that there.
That's a lot of um,
fire coming from this guy and he's real
effective in leading people in hard,
intense situations so that maybe
they just draw that connection.
Maybe it's weird. It's the movies
make it too. Yeah, cause yeah.
People are yelling and boot camp.
Here we go to another
thing from west point.
This is a show fields major general
John show fields of civil war fame.
This is his definition of discipline.
So now this is this,
this is cool because we're talking
about a guy from the civil war, right?
Here we go. The discipline which makes
the soldiers have a free country,
reliable and battle is not to be
gained by harsher tyrannical treatment.
On the contrary, such treatment is far
more likely to destroy then make an army.
It is possible to impart instructions
and to give commands in such a manner and
in such a tone of voice as to
inspire in the soldier. No feeling,
but an intense desire to obey.
While the opposite manner and tone
of voice cannot fail to excite strong
resentment and a desire to Diso Bay.
Okay.
The one mode or other of dealing with
subordinates springs from a corresponding
spirit in the breast of the commander.
He who feels the respect,
which is do others,
cannot fail to inspire in
them regard for himself.
While he who feels enhance,
enhance of manifests,
disrespect towards others,
especially his inferiors cannot fail
to inspire hatred against himself.
So that again,
that what's cool that might sound all
new world be that's written civil war,
civil war, right? That's old school
and he's still talking about,
hey, you got to respect your
people. You've got to treat
them well. That's a great,
that's a great definition of how to,
how to impose,
and I use that word aside. It's
you're not imposing. That's the point.
You're not imposing discipline,
you're,
you're opening the door and
showing the way and leading.
That's what you're doing. Cultivating an
environment of discipline. Yes, very much.
Very nice. I like that. Now he goes into
the various brands of toxic leaders. I'll,
I'll burn through these bully leaders,
those who inflict emotional pain,
delivered threats and ultimatums,
hurl insults and invalidate the opinions
of others. Narcissistic leaders,
those who are arrogant
and self congratulatory.
This brand of toxic leader will often
contrast his own abilities against a
subordinate shortcomings. Look at me.
I can do this so easily. Why can't you?
Okay.
Insular leaders,
this brand of leader forms,
clicks and to great lengths to ensure
that his followers are shielded and enjoy
special privileges. These are all
different brands of toxic leaders.
Hypocritical leaders is the
one you talked about earlier.
These leaders live by the mantra.
Do as I say,
not as I do and rarely
practice what they preach.
The hypocritical leader will hold
a subordinate to a high standard,
but won't apply that same
standard to himself. As a leader,
you should be.
You should be applying a higher standard
to yourself then your people for sure.
Hmm.
Enforcement leaders. This is
interesting. Enforcement leaders.
This mid level leader seeks the approval
of his superiors without regard to his
subordinates welfare. He will
consciously follow orders that are bad,
unsafe, or illegal only to stay in the
good graces of the organizational culture.
That's bad. Those guys, those are
bad leaders. See Him in the military.
They're just, they only lead. They only,
they only do what they're
told to look good,
but everyone hates him
and it's interesting,
like you talk to someone that was
above in the chain of command.
I think all that guy's a
great guy. Yeah. He was super.
Have you talked to someone who's both?
I hate that guy. Isn't that funny that,
that, that, that Schofields definition.
He said you cannot fail
to inspire your hatred.
Hatred. Yeah, sure thing. Treat
people with district. You know that,
that you know what that is? I think that
is psychologically, right? Human beings,
we want to be free. We want
to have, we want to determine
our our path, right? Sure.
When you take that away from
someone and just crush it,
they Dave, they spike you for it and they
hate you for it. Whereas if you can say,
look, you can do this. You can execute
this mission. How you want Echo Charles,
you can do what you want.
Here's the goal.
You figured out a way as opposed to here's
how you're going to do everything my
way.
Next one, callous leader in similar
vein to the enforcement lead,
the Callus leader has a blatant
disregard for his subordinates,
welfare or desires.
Credit hog leaders,
these leaders show exists,
show their toxicity by taking credit
for an employee success or contribution.
They resent the notion of giving
credit where credit is due.
Blame shifting leaders.
The mirror image of the credit
hog is the blame shifter.
This leader is quick to point the finger
for anything that goes wrong and many
times he actively looks for someone
whom he can assign the blame,
the blame shifter.
We'll often maliciously accused someone
of wrongdoing without evidence or
probable cause. That's a person that
does not take extreme ownership.
Hmm. Bunch of toxic leaders
that he talks about it
there.
Here's another
thing he talks about.
As a leader of any stripe,
you cannot simply give orders and expect
your subordinates to them blindly.
To the contrary,
you must establish a clear
intent addressing the why
and the desired end state.
It will never suffice for a leader to say,
because I said so as a
reason for performing tasks.
If you can't justify the
rationale of an order to yourself,
don't make your subordinates do it.
Reevaluate your reasons
and find another method.
Have you ever said that as a parent?
Because I said yeah,
every once in a while you got to
bust that. Oh No, no. It's stupid.
It doesn't make sense to do that.
And when you say everyone's,
while you've got a busted out, like, like
safe emergency situation, hey we look,
I'm telling you, you just can put
your shoes on. We gotta go like, yeah,
because I said so. Yeah. I mean
that's, that's what happens.
And you know what happens in the military
too where you don't always have time.
You know, if you're in a, if you're in a
combat situation, you know you can't say,
hey take that building over there and
the reason why I want you to do that
because blah blah blah. You
don't have time to do that. So,
but you have trust with your subordinates
and they know where you're coming from
and all that.
Interesting.
So really when you really break it
down is you never want to do that ever.
Because I said to him ever, but life's
not perfect. Well this is, this is the,
this is another thing that Leif and I
talk about is there's times definitely
where I was like life hit that building
over there and this is what's cool.
There's also times,
cause I was the guy that wasn't in,
there was also times where life
looked at me and said, Hey Jocko move,
you're out the Humvee over there.
And I was like,
Oh okay cause he needs me to do something.
So we have a mutually
supporting relationship.
It's not about like,
Hey,
I'm the one that's out here
barking all the orders we're doing.
We're trying to get something
accomplished together.
And if he told me to do something,
I know he's got a good reason why.
Because if he had time to tell
me why, he would tell me, hey,
can you put your Humvee over there
cause we're gonna about to, you know,
move guys out in this book,
whatever, Blah Blah, blah, blah.
I'm need to hear all that. Unless, unless
I've got my or Humvee there for reason.
And now he's saying to me like, Hey,
move your home for you. Hey, hold up.
I've got good coverage down this
road. Oh, okay. I didn't see that.
Can you push it back eight feet?
Yeah, we can move it. Okay, cool.
You know what I mean? So it's, it's
good we were cruising like that.
Yeah. But that's, it's,
but as far as like the actual
dynamics of why you shouldn't say,
because I said so because it's not,
in your case,
let's say you don't have time
to explain why. Right. And you,
they just say, hey, move the Humvee.
Right. And you move the Humvee still.
Even if he didn't explain why the
reasons still isn't because I said so.
And you know that
the reason,
the reason is because there's some
tactical situation that's unfolding that,
yeah, of course. Yeah. So it's one of
those things where ultimately you never,
it never, you never should be like,
because I said so never really should,
but in the event of not having
time to explain or whatever,
even there's an explanation needed
in the event of that ever happening,
you need to kind of build trust.
Yes.
So you can kind of alleviate that for the,
for the lack of time or whatever.
What I explained to people when I talk
about life and I on the battlefield that
we had trust with each other. So if we,
you know, if I said to do something,
he'd do it and know that I
had a good reason for it.
If he told me to do something,
I would do it because I know
he had a good reason for it.
And then later on he'd say, yeah, you
know, I need to do that, move that Humvee.
Cause we had, we were blocking the fields
of fire front inside this building.
Like oh okay cool. Yeah. That's
why I moved it. We're all good.
So without that trust being built w
and you put that on top of my expectation
of you to just follow my order without
asking why as a parent or
whatever that is wrong.
It's what you're saying under you
should not say that should not be uh,
leading slash parenting and,
and also you got to remember,
you can get away with
it for a little while,
like a new chief checks into a silk
tune. He says, hey guys, you know,
do this. The guys are going to do it.
Yeah, they're going to do it. There's,
there is a chain of command,
there is a rank structure. Yeah.
But if that's the persistent
methodology of leadership,
it's not going to work for long term.
That's what you got to remember.
And when you do occasionally say that,
like when I would say to
my guys to do something,
they do it like they do it because they,
because it was so seldom that I would
utilize like some sort of the a k do this
now.
I would very rarely exercise that,
that power over the guys.
And it would probably,
I mean I'm just assuming now,
but,
and it's probably because you never
went to the because I said so.
Yes, no, no. Yeah, I don't think I,
I don't think I actually ever said that.
So the less,
even in situations where I would want
to say like snakes sometimes I'm right,
sometimes I'm right, you're wrong.
And I would, I remember there was a,
we're running a block of training and
the guys pulled out this certain element
of training and I said,
hey,
why did you pull out this
element of training? And
they're like, well, you know,
they had some, they gave
their reasons which were all
wrong and I, and I was like,
I was like, well no, here's,
here's the reasons why you're wrong
there and you're wrong there and you're
wrong there. But they were kind of adamant
and I wanted to just say like, Hey,
shut up and do what I'm telling you to do.
You put that,
put that element of
training back in there now.
And I held myself back from doing
that and I'm glad I did. Of course.
I'm glad I did because, because,
because here's the deal.
If you're right and you can articulate it,
I mean eventually I just took me more
time to explain to the guys, hey look,
that element of training,
it might not be happening right now,
but it could very easily happen again
in the future. Here's some examples.
Here's some places we are the world.
Here's other elements that are out there
that are doing that same thing right
now that we could easily get folded into.
So we need to continue to do that type of
training. And they were like, yeah, okay,
make sense? But that was, you know, that
took 20 minutes. That took 20 minutes.
I knew I was right. 100% no, no, no,
no doubt in my military mind at
all. I wanted to just say, hey,
shut up and put the element back
of training. Still didn't do it,
but I didn't do it. [inaudible]
that's how I want to do it. So really,
almost ironically,
the less that you do
say because I said so,
the more you can. Yes,
absolutely. Just what I just
said before. The more you talk,
the less people listen. It's the same
thing. Yeah. You demand people do things.
The less you can demand of them. The
last few demand people, the more you can
use that tool very sparingly as a
leader, very sparingly. And you know,
you kind of went down that rabbit hole.
But this one,
if you can't do this other thing, going
back to the book, I already read it,
but I'll read it again.
If you can't justify the
rationale of an order to yourself,
don't make your subordinates to do it.
This is something I get asked all the
time. They're like, well woof, woof,
and they told you to do something.
Did you do want to do with the Judean
think was right. I wouldn't do it. Hmm.
They're like, well, really? It's like,
yeah, of course. Really? And here's the,
this is what they don't realize.
They think that everyone in the military,
he's like running around giving orders
that are stupid and don't make any sense.
That's not true. You know, when I got told
to do things that didn't make sense of,
one good example of that was was taken
Iraqis with us on the battlefield and
they were saying we had to take a ratio
of like seven to one or whatever the
ratio was at the time. And it
didn't make sense. And I said, no,
we're not going to do that. And I ran up
the chain of command. They're like, yeah,
you're right. Doesn't make sense. You
don't have to do it. Take what you can.
And we were like, okay,
cool. Well there's a,
there's a perfect example of me and been
like, you know, I'm carrying the line.
I'm a company guy,
I'm all on board for the big win.
But if you tell me to do something
that's stupid, I'm not going to do it.
You know, it's funny I heard that
about you. What'd you hear that? That,
that's one of my friends.
You see, we know him,
but he'd be like, Jocko.
So such a bad ass.
Who would like the way he talks to the
superiors is like, it's so gangster.
They'll be like, he was like, no, we're
not going to do that. Doesn't make sense.
You know, whatever. And now
that you're explaining it to me,
it makes more sense because I wouldn't
be that gang in their mind. They're like,
oh my gosh. Yeah, because I would
be explaining it to them, you know?
And you gotta be very careful that
you're not coming across as arrogant,
that you're not coming
across as know it all.
Which sometimes I would have a tendency
to come across like that and I had to be
very careful. I had to check myself
sometimes because you want to,
it's the same thing.
There's like you just like you want,
I want to tell my subordinates,
like shut up and put that element
of training back in there.
You want to tell you your superiors the
same thing and you know, hey, shut up.
That's a dumb idea.
But you can't do that.
And all you're going to do then is what
you're going to do is you're gonna make
them mad at you. That same thing that
he did, I just talked about going down.
The chain of command goes up the chain
of command to, so if, if I treat,
if you're my boss and I
treat you with disrespect,
you're going to hate me and it's going
to work out worse for me because I'm on
the bottom side of that. That little
pyramid we've built. Yeah. So you,
when I would talk to guys,
to my superiors and say that
something doesn't make sense,
I would do in a very respectful way.
And again,
I had to be careful because sometimes,
especially people that didn't know me,
if you didn't know me, maybe that usually
the people that didn't know me well,
I might come across as more
arrogant, you know? And which is bad.
I'm not saying that that's bad.
I wish I wouldn't,
but if I didn't believe in something,
I wasn't going to do it.
And I wasn't gonna be a jerk about it.
But I like, Hey, here's what's going on.
If we take these number of guys in
the field with this many Iraqis,
we're not going to have all the people
that we should have in the field to be
safe. You know, you're talking
about leaving behind a corpsman.
You're talking about leaving
behind a a radio man.
You're talking about leaving behind
a a close air support fires guy.
Those are the guys I can't go on the
field without or someone could get killed
and the the up the chain of command.
I was like, you're right, cool.
And then this didn't happen again.
There would be occasional things,
but it doesn't happen all the time where
people are giving you stupid orders.
My bosses didn't give me dumb, didn't
tell me to do dumb things. Yeah,
and I'm sure that's kind of what
sometimes they told me to do dumb things,
but they were a little dumb things
and you don't have to do the datum.
We did a little pawn things.
You want to do something,
you want me to do something stupid
but it's small and small and stupid.
I'll do it and I'll save my, my
objections to things that actually matter.
Yeah, it makes sense. It
goes back to that paper.
No life talks about doing paperwork
and I was at maybe, you know,
we don't want to do paperwork and I'm like
hey we're gonna do the best paperwork.
Cause it's a little thing, we don't
care about it. You don't want to,
so we've got to stay up an extra hour
and do some paperwork. Who Cares?
We're going to build that trust.
And that way when we'd come
time to say no for real,
we'll be able to say no for real and
the bosses will listen to us. Yeah.
I'm sure that that added to the whole
cache though. You know, where were,
when you did say something or did
push back or whatever it would see,
you'd still get the results,
you know,
where someone who may not understand
that fleet as much as you did.
They just witness kind of that kind
of the end and be like Dang Jack who's
Gainesville. Yeah. You make this
stuff happen up the chain. Yeah.
Cause cause you know, cause to my
guys I might be like, hey guys,
we're not doing that. I'd be like, we're
not doing that. And then be like, oh shit.
And then I go to the,
go to the boss's office and debrief Macer
I'm just wondering about this plan we
got here. I have to do it. Here's
an electric I met, I'd come back.
So yeah, maybe that is, you
know, level three gangster.
All right,
here's another one.
Leaders stay informed of current events
and they should anticipate challenges
based on those events. Just be be informed
of what's happening. That makes sense.
Here's some other west
point lessons learned.
I was able to function
mentally and physically in
top form with only five to six
hours of sleep a night.
Just saying take that for what it's worth.
I don't advocate sleep deprivation,
but I'm just saying there's an example
there that you might want to listen to.
Another thing that he
learned at West Point read.
I love to read books and have an have
since a very young age at west point.
I discovered a magnificent
library loaded with books on
military history in leadership.
Ever since then for
more than 60 years now,
I've been fascinated by the study of
leadership, military, political business,
the athletic,
et Cetera,
and within that a focused
interest in why leaders fail.
Remember a good leader as a lifelong
learner who continually studies to perfect
his craft.
It's interesting to hear these
great leaders read, you know, again,
General Madison is the classic
5,000 books in his personal library.
Hopefully we can get him on the podcast
to discuss some of his favorite books.
Okay. After he graduates from West
Point, he missed World War II.
He goes to Japan and he's
in the occupation of Japan.
Back to the book,
I was flown up to Japan in October of
1945 and was sent north on a train on the
11th airborne divisions jump school
or for the 11th airborne division jump
school,
arriving in Tokyo central train station.
I was struck by the cleanliness of the
place and by the hundreds of Japanese
soldiers in uniform sitting on floors,
leaning against walls,
all on armed no weapons and showing
no anger toward American soldiers.
UH, Japanese rail conductors showed me to
a spotless alcove with a short bunk and
clean sheets.
The train left on time and I arrived
in the next morning exactly on time.
He was my observation.
These people,
we're six weeks out of a five year war
and they had already began cleaning up
and disciplining their services. When
they get back on their feet, watch out.
Even in the midst of defeat.
Carry yourself professionally
and maintain your discipline.
That is the quickest way towards recovery.
Interesting story.
The Japanese.
So we just lost a five year war.
We got atomic bombs dropped
on us. Guess what? Okay,
we lost sign. Unconditional
surrender. Unconditional surrender.
That means you have nothing. You have
no power. Zero nothing. Unconditional.
Unconditional surrender. You know what?
Keep your uniforms on B squared away.
Get the trains running. Clean
this place up. We got to get back.
We gotta get back together.
Got To get back in the game.
It's kind of like if a girl
breaks up with you, right? No,
it's not an unconditional surrender
saying the surrender part.
I'm saying the clean yourself up.
Clean yourself up. For sure. For sure.
For sure. For sure. If
you get back in the gym,
it's the reading develops.
You go when you're, when
you're, no, you're 100% right.
You are right.
When you are defeated,
the best thing you can do
is maintain your discipline.
That's the best thing you can do.
Maintain your discipline. Yeah.
You'd be surprised how quick
he get back on your feet.
There's very few people.
The only, some are, the
reason they're they're jammed
up is because they're not
paying attention things.
They should be paying
attention to them like they're,
they're working out 17 hours a day and
not paying attention to their family.
Those are sometimes those
guys get into scrubs. Right,
and I kind of got to say,
look man,
you're in good shape. You need to
spend some time with your, you know,
with your wife,
with your kids.
Give a little bit back cause that that
happens. The team guys sometimes, yeah.
Gotta be careful that one, we're, we're,
we tend to be workaholics and the work
is so fond that it just like can take
over everything. Wait till, so
what does that, how does that,
does that contribute to their recovery
in other situations? Well, let me,
let's just say there's a family problem
going on, right? And so what does the guy,
dude, he's, he's, he's in
the game, right? He's, well,
he's going to work out even more.
He's going to go to Jujitsu or
even more when what he's doing,
he's not helping the problem. You
see what I'm saying? This is the,
most people don't have that,
but most people have the opposite problem
when they get down, when they get down,
they go, oh, you know, I don't
feel like we're going to own,
I'm just going to drink and
eat pizza and donuts. Right.
That's what most people do.
A lot of time seals will be like,
I'm not feeling good. Cool. I'm
gonna work out harder. You know?
Oh my family is not fun right now.
Cool. The gym is fine, two is fine.
I'll go surfing on a nine day trip.
Dang.
That's like a feedback loop
kind of. Right. In a way.
So it's like okay there's
an issue with my girlfriend.
I'll make it less serious when the issue
with my girlfriend girlfriend's giving
me grief of whatever I'm not around or
something like that or I'm not sensitive
to her feelings.
You know how I'm going to deal with that.
I'm going to go work out guys.
Which makes the problem worse now
because you're paying attention less.
Even less sensitive to her
girlfriend is the one thing though.
The wife is another thing.
Yeah cause the girlfriend,
the guy would be like my uncle,
the wife has a different scenario because
they got kids and the big different,
you just use your example wasn't
good cause you, you took a big,
you took what you thought was a
small step but it is a big step too.
There's too much of a difference than
the different, an example, same example,
wife and kids as opposed to girlfriend,
but yeah, feedback loop. Yeah. Yeah. Your,
this is what I'm saying instead of
instead of the guy going because normal
person, good middle about feeling good
cause my cause, my wife, my girlfriend,
un-normal guy. It's like, hey well
you need to get back in the gym,
get your game together,
get up early,
get on the program and
they'll start feeling good
and they'll start feeling good
about themselves and then they'll start
being a better person and being a better
husband. You say that to a team
guy and they're like, okay cool.
I'll work out in 19 hours a day and
the other five will be doing Jujitsu
or whatever.
Next,
a good leader studies the culture of any
location where he's planning to go and
insures his subordinates are
properly educated on the same.
Here's a good one when in charge,
take charge,
but treat your subordinates with
respect and dignity and common courtesy.
Here's another one.
Oh,
workers performance often reflects
the attitude of his leadership.
If you want something done,
ask nicely.
If a subordinate for guests to perform
a task, don't take it personally.
Just remind them nicely in any
organization, everyone has a to do list.
While juggling these tasks.
Some things will never be fall
through the cracks when this happens.
Don't assume that the
subordinates and lazier, stupid,
simply reengage them on the task and if
necessary, emphasize why it's a priority.
If a subordinate performs a task and
the outcome is not what you expected,
don't attack their
intelligence or character.
Politely explained the deficiencies and
offer an idea for solution suborn it's
quickly lose respect for a leader
who is all problem and no solution.
Speaking of problems, wherever possible,
solve problems at the lowest level.
When leaders are confronted
with disciplinary problems,
be it willful disobedience.
Negligence are honest mistakes.
They must resolve these problems at the
lowest level before raising the issue to
higher echelons.
If the problem can be fixed and
remedy instituted at lower levels,
it will benefit your relationship
with your subordinates.
Improve the health of the organization
and not divert higher level resources
away from their priorities. Solve things
at the lowest I've, well that's, yeah,
that's, I used to say this
exact same thing to my guys,
especially when it, well,
when it came to anything,
but the topic would come up.
A lot of guys getting in trouble. Mm
Kay. If a guy gets in trouble, solve it,
like solve it at your level.
And if you,
and if you don't think you can contain it,
tell me,
what do you mean get in trouble?
Like, oh, guy gets in trouble often.
Do you get to New York? Well, Dui is a
pretty big one, but I got to go fight.
I get to do a fight out in
town. Hey, if you can, hey,
you can punish them. You know,
the platoon chief hears about it
and the platoon chief who says,
I'm going to punish him,
he's going to be doing brass pickup
or whatever he's going to do in some
cleaning the military vehicles.
There's always want, you know,
one of the best oil wax, the six
by, yeah. Um, that, that's the,
that you can handle it there.
You don't need to tell the platoon
commanders platoon, uh, the,
the task unit commander now, it could
be different if the guy gets in a fight.
Now he gets arrested.
Cause now we're going to hear about it
because they're going to find out the
guy's military. They're going to want
to know, contact the chain of command,
because that's what they do.
That's their, that's their policy.
And so now they're going to
contact the chain of command.
So now can it be contained? That's the
question. If it can't be contained,
then you've got to run it up the chain
of command because you don't want your
boss to get, get hit. Uh, what's it
called? Blindsided, right? Yeah. Hey,
one of your truck or one of your guys
was arrested. You know, yesterday.
Why didn't you tell me you don't want that
to happen? Yeah. If you can contain it,
contain it. If you can't, you gotta you
gotta tell the chain of command. Yeah.
But you should try and contain it.
Be like, hey, we got it handled.
Boston was a guy who got in trouble
yesterday. Here's the punishment.
I'd dealt out. And here's what we're,
you know, here's where we're at.
No one wants to be the senior guy with
a secret of, you've heard that before.
Senior guy with the guy with a secret
meaning meaning if you did something
wrong and, and I find out about it,
that means I'm,
I have the secret now and if I'm above
you in the chain of command and now my
boss finds out,
well now I'm going to get in trouble.
So it's be the easiest way for me
to do it is to be like, hey boss,
echo did this wrong. He got in trouble
and then my boss now has the secret.
You guys, are you going to tell his mood
this fully? Right. That's like the friend,
you know,
who catches his friend's girlfriend or
something cheating on him and it's like
shoot, I don't want to do, I
want to ruin the relationship.
Or you know that relationship is
already ruined too. You're right.
That's not a good example.
Maybe that cheating.
Cause there was a movie called,
I think it was called this. Yeah.
I don't know if it was called the secret,
but that's what it was predicated
on and so that's the whole thing.
He didn't want to put it this way. If he
told if he was, if you'd tell the secret,
he would like,
I dunno,
ruined some relationship and if he
didn't it was like they'd be fine,
but you're the senior with a secret.
Then of course at the end of the movie,
you know they, they find out, you
know the big reveal. Who is that?
Vince Vaughn was in it. Anyway,
talk to someone else about that.
To have your own podcast echoed
movie though. Reviews a little bit.
It's the same concept I'm telling you.
Praise in public, punish in private.
I think everyone knows about that.
Here's some,
here's some other left lessons he learned
when he was a occupying force in Japan.
Be Confident but not arrogant.
Self confidence and humility are
the keys to getting any job done.
Little dichotomy in those two.
Obviously there's always a way.
Either you find a way or you make one.
If you can't think of a way,
don't hesitate to ask for help.
Take counsel from those who have
information and experiences.
So funny how some people
won't ask for help,
supervise checkup on things,
but don't micromanage.
Make sure your subordinates
understand their priorities of work.
May need these. I, I'm, I'm, I'm a,
I just realized I was almost
reading those as if like, hey,
we already know these things. It's like
these are things that we know. Not that,
not that they're not important and
obviously how more new and before I did,
he learned them in the
occupation of Japan.
Here he talks about
someone that he worked for.
The officer under whom I served for
the longest period in Japan was Major
Mansfield. He was always
cool, never raised his voice,
very perceptive. Took no wooden
nickels and was a natural leader.
He told me that what he wanted to be
done and let me run with the ball.
He trusted me and I went an extra two to
three miles to make sure I would never
let him down. Never do a shabby
job or never lose his trust.
That right there is this. Like you could
just give that to people and say, Hey,
think about this man. If you're
going to be in a leadership position,
think about this. Yeah, always
cool. Never raise your voice.
Give people what you want to do
and let them run with the ball.
Like that's just basic stuff,
but it's so important.
What's a wooden nickel would Nicole is
it's, it's, it means, it means you take,
you take things that aren't worth
anything. Oh yeah. It's fake. Fake.
A couple more lessons learned.
Tell your subordinate
leaders your standards at the
outset and what you expect.
That's a pretty good one. If you let
people get away with stuff for awhile,
then when you jerk the chain back,
it hurts them more.
Push authority down to make decisions,
but keep responsibility for the results.
Don't blame subordinates for bad results.
Blame yourself for not training them
properly or giving poor instruction.
Stream ownership. Boom. That's
another parenting one for sure.
Always met well.
I see it and then I'll see.
I feel like I've done a good job in being
conscious of this. You know how, okay,
so if I say Kay, so one year old, four
year old, four and a half or whatever,
and I say, Hey, you know, watch him. I'm
going to go grab this thing from my car,
whatever. Watch him. Don't let him
climb up on that bike and fold him.
He's won. So I run in the, you
know, I come back of course,
climb on the bike. Yeah,
falls down. Yeah. Hey,
I thought I told you not to let you
tell the four year old, I know bread.
That's what makes the example even
more powerful because look, hey look,
her failure is my failure that
emphasize my failure even more.
So for a year old, that's my
feeling. Yeah, same thing.
Big Time check.
Be Dead honest with those above
you and below you. Totally candid,
but not harsh, straight
talk. Respect your people.
Taking care of your people is not
just about the obvious things.
Pay working conditions concerned for
their welfare and that of their families,
but seeing that they are properly trained
and have the personal discipline and
desire to get the job
done and get it done well.
Okay.
Carry a notebook or three by five
cards and take notes when being given
instructions or when your boss is
explaining his philosophy or guidance on a
matter.
Okay.
I also found that when running or
doing other physical exercises,
ideas and useful faults
would pop into my head,
possibly related in some medical way.
Blood movement goes to the brain,
so I took scrawling notes when running.
That's not a bad, I've done that before.
I'll be like working out and I'll,
in my workout book I'll have a little
like four words of something I thought of
or like, yeah. Interesting. Yeah. I
don't know if it's that interesting,
but it's worth noting. Oh
yeah. I mean if that's true,
you know like where like you're
carrying a notebook around now.
The nowadays put people
would notes in your phone.
Do you put notes in your phone? Yes.
I put notes in my phone too. Yeah.
Do you take voice memos? Sometimes? No.
I thought, I thought it was so cool,
but I the habit didn't, didn't
stick and stick. Yeah. It's not bad.
I usually type in the,
yeah,
but sometimes if I'm driving
voice note. Yeah. Dang. Okay.
Now he's a company commander in Korea,
so Korean War. So you know there's,
again, we're jumping to this book, but
this is the, I thought this was awesome.
He takes over as a,
as a company commander,
one of my first acts as commanding officer
was to move six men out of the worst
bores nest in the place.
These mortar men had been
billeted in a derelict bunker,
which was infested with rodents.
I moved them into the officer's
bunks and I moved down there,
moved us down there into
the first mortar old bunker.
I had some Korean support troops
creek clean at first though,
and it was very added,
adequate from my gunnery officer,
recon officer warrant officer and
myself, a few mice and bugs, but not bad.
One quarter of my end was
dug into an old Korean grave,
which was immediately covered,
but there's still a lingering odor.
I keep my feet down at that
end and liberal use of an
aerosol bomb and open and
opening the door and it's
not bad sleeping at all.
These graves are hard to avoid.
His tear scattered helter skelter.
All of these hills where
our positions are. So what?
I thought it was awesome about that.
He takes over as company command.
These enlisted guys are living in this
crappy, stinky road and filled barracks.
He kicks them out,
moves them into the officer's Barix.
I moved the officers into the crappy
barracks. That's what I'm talking about.
Okay?
That is legit.
Some more points from Korea.
Good leaders.
Don't wait for official permission to
try out a new idea in any organization.
If you go looking for permission,
you will inevitably find the one person
who thinks it's his job to say no.
It's easier to get
forgiveness than permission.
Put the welfare of your
own troops above your own,
the eat before you eat.
They sleep before you sleep.
Simple acts of courtesy and graciousness
and a profound impact on subordinates,
morale,
self perception and performance.
So every leader is put through an
informal process in the first few weeks
wearing his people,
judge him,
and decide whether or not
he's worthy of their trust.
He must earn their trust. How a leader
must prove himself by his actions,
appearance, demeanor,
attitude, and decisions.
I like that you're definitely getting
looked at when you take over something for
the first time,
you're getting looked at hard.
Hmm?
The leader must be visible
on the battlefield.
He must be in the battle battalion
commander on Down Brigade and division
commander.
On occasion.
He must exhibit his determination to
prevail no matter what the odds are,
how desperate the situation he must
have and display the will to win by his
actions. Words, tone of voice on the
radio in face to face, his appearance,
his demeanor, his countenance,
and the look in his eyes.
He must remain calm and cool. No
fear. He must ignore the dust,
the noise, the smoke, the explosions,
the, the wounded, the yells,
or the deadline around them.
That is all normal,
okay?
He must never give off any hint or
evidence that he is uncertain about a
positive outcome,
even in the most desperate situations.
So again, you know what you
brought up earlier of this. Hey,
we're not going to show any fear.
We're not going to show any
possibility of ever losing, you know,
I don't think he's talking about that.
Uh,
I think he's talking about even though
you might be thinking that I even know
you might give the indication,
hey look,
if we don't get our act together we could
lose this thing but we're not going to
right.
Some more Korea examples.
I'd been taught for years that leaders
must set the example and I tried to do so,
but in battle is absolutely mandatory
and especially so during the Korean War,
at the company level,
I learned that I could keep calm and
functional and the bedlam, stress, noise,
blood and killings of a fierce battle.
I had no choice but to remain calm,
stay in shape when we were not
in battle or another operation.
I took a run in the later
afternoon for an hour or so.
The first reports in the battlefield are
usually exaggerate for good or bad and
are not entirely accurate.
This is normal since they are sent back
by leaders and a moving battle in our
fragmentary first reports are always
wrong. That's what we used to say,
and that's usually pretty true.
Hmm.
Here's a good one.
Be ready so you don't have to get ready.
A good leader will preposition as many
assets and people as he can before an
event, or is it a contingency
in case of disaster? Thus,
when the alert and or
emergency inevitably comes,
you'll be better prepared
to respond to it.
Be ready so you don't have to get ready.
He talked about when
things are quiet in here,
he's talking about when things are quiet
on the line and nothing's going wrong.
Tighten up security.
Be sure the listening outposts are alert,
especially at night and in particularly
if it's raining or snowing,
that's the most appropriate
time for the enemy to close in.
It's interesting how he's talked about
that tall. He talks about it a bunch,
but you know for him, when,
if there's nothing going on,
do something right.
If you've got a day off,
do something to make your position better.
If you're not getting attack, good,
improve your position every moment
he's thinking about that. Yeah.
When you draw up a plan
of attack or defense,
you must have information on the
weather, terrain, an enemy capabilities,
but you cannot coordinate
your plan with the enemy.
Okay.
Therefore, you have to think
through all the what ifs.
Okay.
The enemy does this.
What happens if the enemy does that?
What happens is time well
spent, we, I always say the
enemy gets a vote and that's what he's
saying. Yeah. You, you can corner,
you can make your plans,
but your plans aren't coordinated with
what the enemy's going to do there and at
the enemy's going to do at the end, he's
going to do, hmm. Soldiers in battle,
fight, kill and die and die
primarily for each other.
Okay.
Don't complain to your boss.
Yeah.
He wants solutions,
not just problems.
Okay.
Right. Yeah. And that's
not just to your boss.
That's up and down the chain of
command. Yeah. Saving Private Ryan,
when he said you never gripe down the
chain of command. Yeah, definitely.
I think there was a different point.
Use making buddy. Well, it's, it's, Oh,
I just set up or down chain going
and he's saying, don't gripe up. No,
he's saying don't gripe down.
Go Up. He's saying, yeah.
What he's saying don't gripe up
and you're saying don't gripe down.
And I'm saying don't gripe. Yeah. Yeah.
Well he's saying don't come and
complain to your boss. Yeah. Right.
Yeah. Well, yeah. I, the way I took it on
saving private Ryan Anyway, it was great.
Meaning like I have a complaint about
this that I need the answer to kind of
thing. It's more of a comprehensive
thing that you can not see,
can not delineate the difference
between the Gripe and complain.
They're the same thing.
Well,
I feel like complaining because
it is a wonderful solution.
Complete a complaint is might be a
little bit more formal than a gripe.
Gripe is like, man, I can't
believe we're not getting,
we're getting the same food again. Right?
Yeah. But it's also a complaint. Yeah.
I think you're right about now a
complaint could also be we are low on
ammunition. That's beyond a
complaint. Right? That's like,
that's critical situation to gripe is
less. You think rape is a little bit less,
but they're the same freaking thing.
Yeah.
You shouldn't know either one of them
up or down the chain of you bring
solutions with you.
Okay, so they'll fill up.
That is what I think was kind of like a,
given what I felt anyway and keeps
saving private Ryan. Meaning like, okay,
if you have a,
an official complaint like okay we need
to change this and then again you might
be right because he wants,
he doesn't want you to do it down because
it makes you look like a weak leader
kind of thing. I'm assuming
with this he's saying, Hey,
don't just come with all your
complaints and no solutions to your,
to your superiors cause the superiors and
want answers. They want solutions. Yeah.
Yeah. But when you gripe down the chain
of command there, there's two things.
Number one, if you just complained
down the chain of command,
then the guys are going to
take that and run with it.
But that doesn't mean you don't explain
things down the chain of command it.
That doesn't mean you don't say,
hey guys, we're low on ammunition.
Here's what's going on.
Our vessel transport got
hit in sunk by a torpedo.
They didn't deliver the ammo. We're
going to. Then people go, yeah,
this lesson as opposed to
just the Cape leave. We don't
have enough ammo. Yes, yes,
we don't have enough ammo. This is the
issue. Maybe that's kind of what he meant.
That only goes up. I'm just
trying to think, but both of them,
you have to tell your guys that you
don't have enough ammunition to say,
hey guys,
we have enough ammunition.
Here's what's going on. I put in for
more the the transport, God's sunk and,
and this is the situation we're in.
We need to use our ammo as sparingly as
possible. That's not a complaint. No.
That's an explanation of what's going on
and a commander's intent about how much
Amie ammunition and we're going to
use in conserving ammunition. Yeah.
Check
back to the book. We're
getting into Vietnam shortly
after 9:00 AM on June 29th,
1964 I was handed the colors
of the second battalion,
23rd infantry excepting the colors means
the commander is now responsible for
all his command does or fails to do.
Yeah.
Once you're in charge,
you're responsible for everything.
Now if you remember in we
were soldiers once and young,
there was the loss platoon which
was led by Henry t Herrick,
Lieutenant Henry, t Herrick, and
this guy was known to be aggressive,
aggressive to the point of being
reckless, right? Overly aggressive.
And his sergeant major, and this
is, this is from the book here,
Sergeant Major Plumley told him, colonel,
if you put lieutenant Herrick in there,
he will get all of them killed.
His senior enlisted man,
his sergeant major told him, Hey,
don't put this guy in charge.
He put them in charge anyways.
And he regretted that.
Okay.
And he said that that was one of his
leadership let downs that he failed to
remove a toxic leader from the
ranks and Ann heric soldiers.
Ultimately we're the ones that that paid
the price and therefore he says when
you identify a toxic subordinate leader,
remove them.
If you cannot remove them,
reassign them to a role where
their toxicity can be minimized.
Okay,
so and I mean Herrick [inaudible] those
are, and again you have to get the book,
we were soldiers once and young so you'd
get the whole story because I didn't
cover it in enough detail because it's
one thing that's going on in that,
in that whole scenario and
inherit kind of redeemed himself,
getting the guys together to at least
defend themselves for days out in the
field being attacked like
over and over and over again.
But it was his hyper aggressiveness that
got them in that situation in the first
place.
This is an interesting one.
He's talking about his troops and he
says their duty at their level is just as
important as my duty at my level.
Yeah,
that's, that's awesome. And
I've talked about this before,
how I always wanted like every guy in
my platoon to think that they were the
most important person in the platoon. And
that's what he's saying. And it's right.
It's not just like, I was
like manipulating. It's like,
no, you're the radio man.
Hmm. If we need help, you're the only
person that's gonna get us out. Yeah.
But the corpsman,
if one of our guys gets wounded,
you're the only person that's
gonna be all to save him.
You're the machine gunner. You're the
most important job in the platoon. Yeah.
Without you Blaine down cover fire, we
can't move. Yeah. It's like everyone,
everyone's the most important.
Everyone's job is important
now.
He,
yeah,
he's actually a critical and,
and I got some feedback with, with w on,
we were soldiers once and
young, you know, hair.
Here's a guy that led his troops into
the situation in a bunch of guys died.
And how has that in any way heroic.
And that's valid, right? I mean,
a valid point. We don't. Now the counter
to that is, look, you don't know.
You're going to get
ambushed if you get it.
If you know you're going to get
ambushed like that against, you know,
1500 soldiers, Vietnamese soldiers,
then you would make different decisions.
But we don't know that. We don't know
that we don't have a crystal ball. Yeah,
but here's some of how his criticism of
the way the Vietnam war was fighting.
Again,
this is similar to Hackworth.
Hackworth eventually stood up and
said this out loud during the war,
which is why he got so much criticism
from the army and also one of the reasons
why I like Hackworth so much is because
he did what I was talking about earlier.
He was like, no, I don't believe in
doing this and we're, we're, we're,
we're not going to win this way.
He said that,
okay,
here's what,
how more says from 1964 and to the
American withdrawal in 1973 our objectives
kept changing from political stability
and preventing an enemy takeover to
preserving the independence of south
Vietnam and training the Arvin forces.
At first,
the u s pushed the South Vietnamese
army aside and took the war over with a
brand of fighting that only
American forces and American
logistics could support.
When we left in 1973 our
heritage was just that,
a form of war that the South Vietnamese
and its armed forces could not sustain.
In the late 1970s the army
chief of military history,
General Douglas Canard,
wrote a book called the war managers.
Okay.
He sent a questionnaire to 175 army
generals who had served in Vietnam.
His book is the analysis of their replies.
Nearly 70% of those generals were
uncertain and unclear as to what the U s
objective was in Vietnam.
Damn,
that's horrible.
That's absolutely horrible.
Hundred and 75 generals.
Okay.
And 70% of them didn't know
what the objective was.
Now, if you got the genitals, you
take that down a step to the kernels,
to the battalion commanders,
to the company commanders,
to the platoon commanders,
to the squad leaders.
You get down to the front lines and guys
have no idea what they're doing there.
How do we expect to accomplish the mission
when no one in the chain of command
really understands what it is that the
objective is, what the mission is? Hmm.
Okay.
So
with that,
Colonel Moore says, a leader must
have clearly defined objectives.
He must ensure that these objectives are
clearly understood by his subordinate
leaders.
Lesson learned.
Yeah.
Here's a,
speaking of family life,
there are at least five activities that
must be kept in balance through proper
time management. These five activities
are the job, physical fitness,
personal time alone,
recreation and social relationships.
Also if they apply to others,
religion and family.
If any of these get out of balanced
in life gets out of balance.
From my own personal experience
and observation of others,
being a workaholic is the most
common area of imbalance. And again,
that's what I saw a lot with with with
the guys. I used to work with the,
they are workaholics and not only that,
you know,
you meet business guys all the
time, you're not, you're not.
There's so many business guys
that are workaholics, businessmen,
business women that are out there.
They're grinding,
they love it and they don't want
to stop. And that's again, that's,
that's problematic. It's not, it's not
the most common, but business leaders,
why are they in a leadership position?
Because they built something.
Why did they build something?
Cause they wanted to win because
they wanted to take over.
Well that doesn't just stop at a certain
point. It keeps going. It keeps growing.
You reach one goal and you've
set another one, a higher one.
That's the harder one that keeps going.
That'd be careful of that one balance.
After Vietnam he went and took over
a base where they were running basic
training and here's what he
said about basic training.
The goal was for every man leaving
basic combat training to be in the best
physical shape of his life and to know it,
to stretch his mind and his muscles and
to assist him and thereby gaining more
pride in himself, more self confidence
and above all more self disciplined.
A man who has more self discipline,
has more confidence in
his ability to do the job.
I got asked a while back and we answered
it on the podcast, but you know,
guy said, hey, I took over a
unit. They're kind of downtrodden.
What do I do to get their, their pride
back up? It's like, yeah, work them hard.
Do hard training.
That's what you do.
Discipline.
Okay.
Hard training.
Give them something to brag about.
Give them something to take pride in.
Yeah,
he was dealing with Vietnam protestors
when he was running that base and he just
said, guys don't even show
your weapon known. Don't even,
we're going to completely underreact
not going to give them what they want.
And that's the one who is tenants here.
Don't overreact and never
overreact to an overreaction.
And I'm going to close this out
with a pretty big chunk here,
but this is when how more
got back from Vietnam.
He wrote a little piece called
Lieutenant leadership in combat.
Okay.
And here's what he says.
This is a compilation of a few of my
views on leadership of and by lieutenants,
specifically infantry platoon
leaders in a combat zone.
It will be somewhat mixed in perspective
and is not possible in these few words
to get across my full views on leadership.
In my judgment,
a leader builds over time,
his own unique brand of empathy or lack
of it with his subordinates and creates
his own leadership, debits and
credits with those under his orders.
So you've heard me talk about
leadership capital, same thing.
He's talking about their leadership,
debits and credits. He does not.
He does. He does this through personal
contact and shared experience based on the
interplay between leader and lead.
Working with mixed perspectives shaped
by the dynamics of real time and real
life.
Leadership is a highly
personal individual matter.
Each leader must establish
his own approach based on
an internal compass using a
method geared to his personality,
his capabilities,
but always oriented toward accomplishing
the mission while knowing and taking
care of his men. Now, while he says that,
yeah,
you got to come up with your own,
your own method of leadership.
They're the fundamental principles that
he talks about that we talk about all
the time that we wrote about.
Those don't change.
You got to find your methodology of
presenting them and carrying yourself.
But the fundamental
principles are fundamental.
Hmm.
As officers,
we are given groups of men to lead
other officers and Ncos and enlisted
soldiers. Each has a different
background, different problems,
a different outlook and different duties.
But no matter what their background
or their previous experience,
no matter how much love,
care and effort may have been spent over
the years by their parents and raising
them when they are turned over to us,
are now ours.
Take care for at that instant the parents,
teachers or system that brought them
to that point, we'll be in the past.
Their lives and future
are largely in our hands.
This is a terrible responsibility
for a fire team leader to have,
not to speak of a battalion,
a division or a corps commander.
You got all these different people
coming in and you're responsible for now,
and I'll tell you,
I've had this conversation with business
leaders to business leaders are the
same way because when you're
paying someone's paycheck,
they're feeding their family, their
pay, they're paying their mortgage,
they're saving for their kids to go to
school. They're paying their car payment.
That's their life.
And if you as a leader are
not helping them to achieve,
you're letting them down.
Okay.
Now is it the exact same thing as having
their actual life or death in their
hand? No, it's not the same thing,
but the pressure is there. Yeah.
Okay.
Among other attributes.
Yeah.
I feel soldiers of any rank must
have confidence in four directions.
The first is to have self confidence
developing. It leverages many resources,
the primary sources,
expert knowledge of his assigned duties
and readiness at any time to take on the
next higher job.
So you don't 100 people just
trained to do their job.
You want them to be able to step up and
do the next job above them and the chain
of command. In addition to creating
confidence through individual expertise,
his superiors, facilitators, development
through trust in how they treat them.
This is imperative. Every person's
dignity must always be respected.
I feel that if anyone under me fails,
the fault is at least half mine.
A man should never be caused
to think poorly of himself.
And this requires a subtle and
sensitive touch by the leader,
especially when taking
disciplinary action.
So the first thing he wants you
to have his self confidence,
right and you develop it
by how you treat them.
Second but non priority or
in not in priority order is
the necessity for each to
have complete confidence in his personal
weapon as well as any other weapon he
might have to handle to include using
radios and the knowing procedures and
knowing the procedures for requesting and
controlling mortar and artillery fires
developing. This takes leader
controlled leader supervised training,
so you want to be good at your job,
you want to be expert in your job,
the the,
the more expert you are in your job,
the more confident you're going to have.
The third confidence in the unit
and the men who are fighting.
The third is confidence in the unit and
the men who are fighting with him at
whatever level. The leader must
strive to develop an intense,
a spree decor but never by
running down other units.
An example of what not to do is to permit
internal sub units to be so disloyal
to the organization as a whole
as to critique, criticize,
snipe or run down sister units beat
a squad platoon or company on up.
It is self defeating and terrors.
The unit as a whole.
It tears down the unit as a whole,
so
you want them to have esprit de corps,
but you don't want them
to get it by cutting it.
Other units that are within your team.
Fourth and so vital. A man must have
confidence and trust in his leaders.
He must know an utterly believe
his leaders are competent
professionals who know
what they are doing and are not
careless or casual in their outlook.
Look toward their responsibilities.
For a subordinate to be confident in
his leader, the subordinate must know,
the leader is aware of and appreciates
what the subordinate must face and the
life he must lead in performing his job.
The leader must make every effort to
get inside the heads of his men and see
their problems and the
world from their viewpoint.
Got To get the perspective of your people.
You got to understand what they're going
through. You know, he talked about,
and we were soldiers once
and young that in the,
in the civil war that the officers,
it was like bad if you can ride your
horse all the time because then you didn't
understand the guys
who were marching with,
they're going through and in Vietnam
some guys were riding the helicopter,
all of this,
some commanders would stay
over the battlefield at 2000
feet out of a small arms
range. We're safe up
here. Nothing can happen.
But you forget what those guys are
going through down there on the ground.
Yeah. The gyms and Jujitsu.
I'm the instructor gems em up
sometimes when you know, when you free,
you're trying to teach someone something,
and I said this before,
he called the curse of knowledge where
you don't, oh yeah, you're so advanced.
You forgot what the white belt is going
through in his learning, you know,
so he started teaching stuff and you know,
they,
you forget that they need to know this
stuff first before they can pick up this
other stuff. You know, you need
perspective. Their perspective.
Yeah.
Back to the book.
This takes some doing and while the
leader cannot be intrusive into personal
affairs, he must help solve
personal problems if he can,
especially if the problem's penalize
individual or unit performance.
For example, in garrison and to
some extent, even in a combat area,
most disciplinary problems
stem from women, alcohol,
firearms, control, money
and vehicles. This is,
this is from my old job. This is 100%
true. Women, Alcohol, firearms control,
not so much money in vehicles for sure.
Yeah, guys crashing cars, guys, Duis,
guys crashing motorcycles.
Guys getting in trouble with girls.
Drinking age is encompassed in all those.
Knowing this,
a leader can perform a lot of preventative
maintenance as an isolated but not
sole example.
Pay problems often arise for separated
families living on limited income.
Many of these can be eliminated
in advance by real leadership.
In summary,
my views are take care of the troops,
develop four way confidence
and be professional.
Okay.
This ensures we can carry out our first
duty accomplishment of the mission.
Finally,
concerning professionalism.
Okay.
I believe even now the clock is
bringing us closer to some few seconds,
minutes or hours.
In the future when the professionalism
we will have or will not have.
Okay.
We'll make a life or death difference
for the men placed under our leadership
and whose families can
only trust hope and pray
that we know our business.
Yeah,
and again,
there's more than that book,
but I think we'll close it out there
because what a thing to keep in your mind.
Just keep that in your mind that even
now the clock is bringing us closer,
closer to a moment when your
okay.
Leadership will be tested
and it is your professionalism
and that means your ability,
your mental and physical strength,
your knowledge, your judgement,
it will all be tested at some point.
Have we done enough to
prepare for that moment?
Have we trained hard enough?
Have we studied hard enough?
Have we read enough?
Have we learned enough?
Are we prepared?
Okay
for what is coming?
And I think that's all
I've got for tonight.
So Echo, speaking of being prepared. Sure.
Maybe you can give us some advice on
getting a little more prepared. Sure.
Be Glad to
prepared for,
I'll start with k preparation for Jujitsu,
few through references,
usually through his life.
Grappling is like,
do you do to this life and
youth are these life by the way,
there's a lot of similarities, I would
say Nesians age you did to his life.
Well if you say that then that's cool.
The metaphor. No, no, no, no, no, no.
But for some people Jujitsu to life,
yes. They're just training. Yeah. Good.
Good for them. Yeah, maybe. Yeah. It
shouldn't be your whole life. Yeah.
Some other things. Yeah. I didn't
mean it that way. I meant it.
Like Jitsu reflects life. It's
like a metaphor for life. Yes.
In the event,
have you been in Jujitsu?
Like many people are and
more people are becoming,
a lot of people ask me what Geeta
get. I know. Yup. I'm going into it.
You get an origin g, that's
how many do you have?
Four. Four, okay. I have three. Okay.
Every single one of them is outstanding.
Yeah.
Designed outstanding.
Designed,
designed here though here in American
America and the recent Jujitsu players,
by the way. Yeah. Jujitsu players. So
I was, I watched, um, one of their,
one of Pete's videos and it was,
if you go to their youtube channels, you
know, the, how you have the main video.
Yup. It's watching that and
it made sense, you know,
you'd see everyone that's
part of the factory,
they kind of give their input in the
video a little bit and it made sense.
So like, you know, like there's a
lot of geese that are made, you know,
kind of thing. But if it's made by
Jujitsu people, they're going to know,
like when you put on a ski jacket,
they're going to know the
difference between a g.
That's that whoever designed it had this
in mind. When you put your hands up,
what's that Geek gonna do you
know, if you're just, Oh, I'm just,
I'm going to make a geek.
And they don't necessarily do Jujitsu,
they might not pay, pay attention and
that kind of stuff. Or, um, you know,
when you did, you did, let's
face it, like if you do karate,
your body goes through a certain thing,
right?
While you're doing karate in
whatever capacity. If you do Jujitsu,
your body is going to go through a certain
thing and more appropriately your g
is going to go through a
certain experience and you
can't use a karate d for
this. You Shits. That's one
of the things I'm saying.
So let's say the way you put on and keep
on a karate GI or a Jujitsu g is going
to be going to play a role
in when you do Jujitsu.
So like you tie, you know when you
tie your pants or something like this,
how your pants are tied
matters when you do Jujitsu.
True. Just like how you belt it in
your belt is tight. It matters anyway,
Pete and these an origin,
they kept that in mind when they
designed it and it shows too, by the way.
So anyway,
these are some of the reasons that you
should 100% get an origin g if you're
still wondering what key to
get more important in that.
If you don't do Jujitsu and that's
why you don't need to start Jujitsu.
Yeah.
Then you'll need again,
you'll need to get you started
Jujitsu and this was done.
The parallels between you two to in life
and you'll get in good shape and you'll,
you'll learn to defend yourself.
Real situations,
recalibrate your instincts,
which are completely wrong.
By the way, there are wrong.
Yes. If you are right now,
if you're listening and you're thinking,
you know, my instincts aren't that bad.
No,
I'm telling you that long.
If you don't think they're
wrong [inaudible] academy
and tell him you got good
instincts. Let's roll.
Yeah. Here's one in life.
Do you want to turn your back
to your problems in life?
No. You do not in Jujitsu.
Do you want to turn your back
to your no, you do not. Okay.
But your instinct might tell you
in a fight and sometimes in life,
cause that's what we do sometimes. See
that's where, that's why, how more more,
sorry. We're not listening to our
instincts all the time. Not all the time.
Not all the time, but
we don't follow them.
You can listen to it and that's
a caution. Right? But no, no, no.
He's saying if they're predicated on your
education experience, learning, reading,
reading,
right.
So essentially you are going to listen
to your recalibrated instincts after you
train in Jujitsu with your origin Geek.
Cause that's when you can get,
because that's the best one. Straight
up. That might sound like an opinion,
but it's a straight up fact.
You get these keys@originmain.com.
They have some other stuff on
there, some apparel, rash guards,
compression gear.
That being said,
there's also other stuff.
Supplemental stone supplements.
Okay, so Krill oil, uh, you know,
he's talking about the supplements that
I think Jocko thinks I'm being for you
right now. What a good
supplements. Krill oil,
joint warfare. These are things
to maintain your structure,
bodily structure that to scientific Sony.
No,
I don't think you have the
capability of sending to scientifics
and grill. I think you
might be right. Nonetheless.
That was one of those digs
I was talking about earlier.
Like I don't mean it in a bad way, but it
kinda come across like I'm a jerk. Yeah.
What do you think? I'm stupid. I'm stupid.
Things don't sound real scientific.
Should I just not talk anymore? Some
people would support that answer that.
Anyway. Supplements? Yes. Jack has an
echo lovers and there's echo haters. Okay.
They're both, there's two camps.
The ecolodge is a bigger camp.
Hopefully the echo haters
is a louder camp. Yeah,
and it makes sense.
The grapes,
I think they come up the
chain or down the chain.
Both. Yeah. Man, it makes sense to
me. If you're honest, you're honest.
There it is. Nonetheless, back to
supplements. Chocolate, the supplements,
they're good. Supplements,
supplements. Chocolate actually takes,
see that's a big deal. Do what I
say, not what I do in this case.
Look disciplining me right now. You're
doing all kinds of bringing stuff back.
Closing the loop on the podcast.
I'm just trying to learn these things.
Apply them to my life and in
this particular situation,
life is telling the people about
joint warfare and Super Krill oil.
Anyway. It's a Omega threes
in the Krill oil. Obviously.
If he didn't know about Krill oil,
I think that
Krill oil ended up to be one of
those. Sleeper, what do you call them?
Sleeper supplements.
You know where you like it.
It's been going on the whole time
but you didn't know about it.
You didn't know about it. I'm
not about it, Kevin. That's me.
Nonetheless Jocko has it takes it.
I take it and I will
say 100% effectiveness.
My opinion or do you mean scientific
opinion? The scientific, yeah, big time.
Double blind tripled or demean.com
that's where you get it.
Also for a pre mission supplement.
New Supplement Chocos supplements.
It's called disciplines like a
preworkout cognitive enhancer.
Is that accurate?
You could call it that.
It's pre life life. You have
Michigan cause what's your mission?
Because I just don't need
cognitive enhancement when I,
when I'm going to get in the game.
Sure.
I also need to have physical
force multiplication. Yeah.
So that's why we made it.
Yeah.
Cause I wanted cause cause when I
do stuff it's physical and mental.
It's physical and mental. You need
to be, both of those need to be
tuned up.
Yet some fire did so enhanced if you will.
At the very least it should
be squared away. Yeah.
Well and the good thing you can feel it.
Yeah,
see and that works real good for Jujitsu
cause Jesus is one of those things.
Let's face it,
if I'm doing a bench press,
you know people have asked me all the
time like who did you take a pre workout
in the morning? Cause I get up early
in the morning going to work out.
I do not take a pre workout in the
morning before I go and work out in the
morning. No. Oh yeah. You don't want to
talk discipline? No I don't drink driving.
I go in there, I drink water, I
brushed my teeth and drink walker.
Then I go on and do my morning workout.
So I do not take a pre workout or a
nootropic prior to working out in the
morning.
However,
for the Shark Shitzu there is a,
I would say I'm about 60
or 70% of the time I'm on,
on the discipline when I go in there
because you can feel it like it.
You can feel better. Like why
not have good training. Yeah.
And that is one of those things like life
is one of those things where this kind
of supplement makes 100% sense because
it is physical and mental and not just
Ooh, you know, like everything's mental.
I get it. Yeah. Your brain dresser I get,
it's true. Even if you're doing,
you know, bench press or whatever,
he's still mental for sure.
But did you to like your mind
has to be going at the same pace.
You're using your mind just as much if
not more during Jujitsu or you're using
your body by the way. I think if
you were going to do a little, okay,
so in the mornings I don't need
it. Yeah Bro. I don't need it.
Like I don't,
in the morning I'm ready.
Like I wake up and I'm like
ready to rock and roll. I don't,
I'm, I'm going to get in there.
I'm going to get it. Get it. Yeah.
I will say this during a
over the Christmas time,
some of my workouts in the morning because
I had other responsibilities during
that time period cause you got early
morning tactical things that you're doing
around Christmas,
et Cetera.
And because he got kids and whatnot and
so some of my work and then in the APP
when I was working on the afternoon,
I was getting on the discipline in the
afternoon because it's not the morning
time anymore. Them a little bit. So
you're like one guy who like, you know,
certain people they have their,
they're like uh, what do you call it?
Like time of day where they're
kind of peaks their potential.
I think my performance actually peaks
in the afternoon. Like most people.
I think that's the most common time.
But in the morning when I get up,
I'm ready to rock and roll
is what I'm saying. I don't,
I just want to get in there
and get it done. Like I'm,
I feel like I missed out a bunch
of stuff when I was sleeping.
Like what just happened?
I kind of feel the opposite.
I feel like when I'm working on with
like, Dang, I could be sleeping.
You need the discipline. Nonetheless.
It's called discipline. The pre mission,
we call it a pre mission. Yes.
Supplement. Yes. It's good.
It's a good good name or do you
mean.com that's where you get it.
Also for kick ass fitness gear on
it.com/jocko I get the kettle bells.
I have the kettle bells. My collection
is girl. I'm going for all of them.
That's my, that's my my my goal.
Clear and concise. Cool. You know,
if you want a, if you want to make
your workout routine more interesting,
there's a lot of cool stuff on their
battle ropes maces and you can look up all
the workouts you want to do. I think
there's a big deal for people unlike you,
by the way, who don't mind doing
the routine routine. Your team,
you want to mix it up.
That's what I think anyway.
Audit dotcom slash Jocko, the street.
You can get them awesome stuff.
Also when you get the book,
we were soldiers once and young and also
how more on leadership winning
when outgunned and outmanned,
that's what it's called. When you're
getting these books. Don't worry.
I have the list of books including
this one by episode on the website,
Jocko,
podcast.com and while you're doing that,
make a note to yourself that you need
to put the link to the new extreme
ownership because somebody tweeted me
that you have the old extreme ownership
linkedin there, which is not good.
Are you guys selling the old one?
I don't think you can get any
more if you can get it. Well, no,
I don't think I can get it more. Just
the new one. All right, get sold out.
All right. There you go. Boom. Yet another
book on the list and that list is at,
like I said, [inaudible] dot com go to
the top on the menu there. Click on books.
Boom. All the books, including the ones
that we, the one we went over today,
extreme ownership. I'm gonna call
it the new one. What do you call,
what's the official? The new
one. The new one. That's it.
The black one. The black one.
The black cover. Yeah. It's
got the black cover. Yeah,
there it is. Anyway. Either way. Yeah,
it's the new one has
excerpts from the podcast.
When we talk about leadership on the
podcast, the really prominent questions,
right?
Put some of those interviewed there.
They're included in there and there's
also a new forward and there's new
pictures in their color pictures.
I ain't held the line.
Tried to hold the line pictures.
Color pictures are cool man. For them.
It's a step up for me to step down.
I don't mind the color pictures. I think
they're cool. Um, but yeah, there it is.
Nonetheless. You can get it all odd
duck and stop. Come in the book section,
Click on there.
It's a good way to support boom.
Takes it to Amazon and do some shopping
on there with these books here or
whatever else. Hey, carry on. That's
how also subscribe to the podcast,
iTunes, stitcher, Google
play, all these podcasting,
providing platforms. If you
haven't already, leave a review.
If you're in the mood, if
you're in the mood, if you're
compelled to leave, review.
Also Youtube,
we have a youtube channel.
I haven't read any podcast reviews
on the podcast in a long time,
so maybe this,
there's some really good ones.
The funny ones. Yeah. There's some
funny ones that's like, I'm like, good.
Doesn't mean like, Hey, this
is the best podcast ever.
Good, right. You're just, yeah,
something that's funny and creative and
it's still good. Yes, of course. Well,
because in your way of saying good,
it can still be a negative review as
long as it's good. A good one. Yeah,
sure what I'm saying. Yeah. I mean,
I don't recommend let me sleep,
but as far as your criteria for the
word good in this specific case.
Good, good, good review. Good
entertaining. I should say entertaining,
entertaining. They're just the
same with same with on Amazon. Yes.
There's some entertaining reviews.
I've read some of those.
I'll read some more of those because
they're good people put time and effort
into those. Yeah, they do for sure
and their and their sense of Umer.
Yeah. I support that
too, by the way. Also,
like I said, youtube screw, right. We
have a youtube channel, Jocko podcasts,
what it's called, it's what it's
called, youtube channel. Boom.
I've got some extra ups on there if
you'd want to necessarily watch the whole
two, three hour podcasts, video format,
some excerpts on there and it
takes specific lessons. Boom,
all on the youtube channel. Most
of them, all of them, most of them.
Nonetheless. I'm also a tiny
fraction of them actually. You know,
some of them will say also there are
deleted scenes every once in a while I'll
put some deleted scenes if you care or
are interested in what Jocko digs at me
about while we're not actually technically
we're recording but it's not part of
it. PODCASTS, prerecording free
recording if you're interested,
that kind of stuff. It's on the youtube
every once in a while I'll post them.
Also, Jack was a store,
it's called Jocko store.
Obviously this is where you can get,
if you want the shirts,
shirts, hoodies, maybe some hats
on their rash guards. Strangely,
a lot of people who've been hitting me
up for rash guards and I've been seeing
him out in the wild way more recently.
People are getting after it. Big Tim
where he could rest.
Guards are on there for the youth
youth sizes towards a lawyer.
Kids. Yeah, exactly. Right. Boom.
They're up up shipping going out already.
I'm also, we have a new one on there.
Just if you want any of this stuff.
This is where you can get them. Jocko,
store.com some good stuff, girl.
Stuff on the women's stuff on
there. Also, psychological warfare.
If you didn't know what that is,
I know I've explained it before,
but in the event of you not
hearing it yet, this is what it is.
It's an album with tracks,
not songs.
They're Jocko tracks.
So basically what these structure
for are your in you file.
You're going to keep it
concise for a moment. Now.
Well here's the thing I
think is important. If you
can do it in 10 seconds, no,
I can't do it in Texas.
10 seconds.
I'm not going to do our people the
disservice of making it 10 seconds.
This,
this is,
this product was made for me is my
product essentially true statement when it
comes down to it. So when you
come, okay, here's what it is.
When you come across your moment,
it's a weakness in life.
Okay? Sounded like you were
right there. Little bit
miss in life. Like you know
you're waking up early, right?
You want to keep it consistent all year,
New Year,
new me waking up early every single day.
Maybe not on Sundays or maybe
Sundays too, I dunno. Whatever.
Either way when you wake up, sometimes
you're not going to feel like it.
Sometimes you're going to
want to hit the snooze. Boom,
put in one of these tracks.
It's Jocko on there telling
you pragmatically giving
you practical advice on why
you shouldn't hit the snooze.
Same thing with skipping workouts.
Same thing with cheating on the Diet.
Do you call it cheating on the Diet?
I don't know what you call it.
I call it eating donuts. Eating
donuts, slipping out the Diet.
You know he didn't need speed bumps.
Weakness, speed bumps is what they are.
Yeah. Speed bumps. Some job.
I had some chocolate cake
with mint chocolate chip
ice cream on all of this and
it was good. How many times? More
than once. No, I, you know what?
I had twice in the same
situation like boom,
I'm back again.
Boom.
Two hits and boom buddies like chocolate
cake with mint chocolate chip ice cream,
which is not normal, so that's
right, like kind of got me.
I wasn't listening to the psychology
course or I see that's a perfect example
where actually that's not a perfect
example because I'm sure you were kind of
like, hey, freedom. Yeah,
that was the freedom. You are
free. You are a discipline.
You're exercising the freedom part. This
is for times where like you're at work.
I'm actually fasting right now other
than having some Jocko white tea and some
discipline. I'm fasting. Yeah.
People. Some people are like,
whatever.
I had 27,000 calories a day
to eating four calories a day.
Still not fasting. I
think zero. I don't know.
I'm not an expert either way.
What this is about. What a, um,
psychological warfare, what, what you
were done. Who It's for? No, no, no, no.
You are numb.
The whole explanation that had been done,
we're still on not album
tracks. You sit. No.
You said you use the example
of you eating chocolate
with ice cream as one of the scenarios.
The chocolate cake had like a
hard shell of chocolate on it.
That is the reason I
asked how many times can,
was kind of melted a little bit.
That's how
well you do it with like a Brownie, so
it melts. Actually it's kind of the same.
There's not a restaurant in
San Diego, ob, California,
it's called Raglan. And they have
something there called the legal.
Yeah. Because it's so good that
it should be leading. Right.
And it is, it's a, it's
no big deal. Right.
This is what makes it so
good is it's just the, uh,
a little cast iron pan,
just a little cast iron pan and they
cook a chocolate chip cookie it. Yeah.
And then they put vanilla ice cream on
that thing is, should it be illegal?
Yeah. Yeah. That might be, you know what,
my psychological warfare
might not work against that.
Even Ragland that's saying
watch out for that one.
That's saying a lot because as of right
now, I think it's 100% success rate.
Actually 101% so I heard,
I heard out in the field reports,
but you were saying,
you were saying that that's the
example when to use it. It's not,
oh the example is when you're on the path,
but you feel like the moment of weakness.
I don't think the chocolate chip,
that was a conscious decision of,
yeah, you know, it's the holidays,
I'm going to do this,
you know, kind of thing.
I'm an extra in my freedom because
of one of my discipline. All that.
It's like when you're at work, it's not
lunchtime yet. It's almost lunch time,
but not quite yet. Boom,
they got the donuts. Right.
Cause there's some big office meeting
they want to cater, you know, whatever.
It's that kind of situation because
you don't have that, so it's good dude.
That's what's good fasting. Recalibrate
that, that little hunger vibe,
unless you hit a speed bump of
weakness during the fast yeah.
Then you can by the way. Yeah. Oh
yeah, for sure. Like peanut butter,
like there had been fascinating.
The biggest thing that I think the biggest
thing someone was asking me about it
the other day.
Um,
well the, the reason he's like,
what's, what's the hardest part?
Like the first eight hours, the first 12
hours, the first 24 hours. And I was like,
the hardest part of a fast is the parts
where you're not doing something. Yeah.
Like I haven't thought about eating one
time during while we've been recording
this podcast.
I haven't thought about eating.
One time when we get done and we
square ourselves away and you leave,
I'm going to be like, cool, what
am I gonna do now? You know?
But then if I was to go from here
and like drive to go do something,
I wouldn't think about it. Are
you talking to the phone? Yeah.
You got something going on? How
long has this, I don't know.
I think I'm actually going to eat
this afternoon or this evening. Oh,
so you're like, Hey, I'm just going to
fast. What do you have a minimum amount?
I know I'll do like 24 hours.
You said do 24 hours once a month and
then I'll do 72 hours once a quarter.
Yeah,
I'll have,
I'll have a few handfuls of mixed nuts.
Like throughout the day I'll grab a
handful of mixed nuts. I'll have some tea,
some Jocko white tea by the way.
Uh,
revisit the first one
where I've done discipline,
which I think is really good
cause it's making me feel great.
So and like there's no calories in it
orders one calorie or something really
small in there. Yeah. But yeah, and,
and recalibrates your hunger
sensitivities and man,
I feel good when I do it. So have
you done it? You have 24 hour fast.
You feel good, right? You
feel good enough? Here's it.
Here's the thing. Wait, wait.
24 hours. Yeah. I use 24.
I actually probably do 24 hours more
than once a month because a lot of times
I'll just wake up, I'll be traveling
and I just won't eat. Yeah.
And so I ate the night before. I wake
up early in the morning, I go, I travel,
I get somewhere at night
and then I eat dinner.
Well that means I just went
24 hours without eating.
And that's kind of essentially kind
of how it happened for me early on.
But after a while you're like, you
know the kind where you like, Dang,
I'm totally miss lunch,
but I don't want to eat.
No because I won't be hungry for
dinner with the family kind of thing.
So I'm like, Hey, I'm not going to eat.
Then I'm like, wait, hold on. Sorry.
I just went 24 hours.
You know what I've noticed this time,
and like I said,
it's only been 36 hours right now.
But what I've noticed
this time is the actual,
I felt good about exercising discipline.
Like I felt good about like I'm not
eating that because maybe it's because,
because I just, I've been
thinking to myself and like, yeah,
I don't need to eat right
now and that feels good.
I've been actually enjoying the
discipline of it, which is, uh,
normally I don't enjoy the discipline
of it. Normally I haven't, none that,
I don't, I've never even thought about
it before this time I've been like, yes.
Yeah, that makes sense. I'll shut
you down, man. I don't remember.
I know we don't talk
about seal training a lot,
but when you go through hell week,
which is like when you
stay awake for five days,
one of the things that I thought about
when I was going through hell week was
like, oh, it's going to feel so good
to sleep when I get done with this,
that it kind of made me feel good
to do it. Like I was like, aw man,
can you imagine how good it's going
to feel when I get done with this?
I could go to sleep and it's going to
feel so good and right now I'm kinda like
the same thing. I'm kind of thinking, oh,
this feels so good to not to not eat
right now because in two days I'm going to
eat and it's going to be solid.
It's the same way. I feel strangely,
not strangely,
but same way I feel when I go on vacation
or I'm like if I didn't do a lot,
a lot of work for the, you know,
the past two months or whatever.
Like let's say work is
like kind of cruise.
We'll say like he didn't like test me.
You know how like
if I shoot all day,
like at the muster,
I'm kind of shooting all day from four
30 [inaudible] everyone is talking about
taking pictures and I'm like,
where are you shooting?
I don't shoot guns for,
no, I do nonetheless.
Will you do a few musters you make
some big, you know in my case,
you know you do work and then you're like,
oh you're looking forward to that
vacation kind of thing. But it was like,
oh you have a trip planned but you
haven't been working that hard.
You'd like the Brown one. I like, I
want to stock up on a bunch of hard,
hard work so I can enjoy that.
Vicky. You know what I mean?
So the vacation seems more appealing.
Same thing. Yeah. It feels good.
It feels good. Give it a try.
Check with your doctors. Right.
I guess what sue before you fast.
But nonetheless,
if back to the speed bump thing,
if you hit your mom,
so we know we can carry this through.
Why psychological warfare is good
because sometimes you hit those malls,
you've said about it, you never said,
hey, you can get it on apple, iTunes,
Amazon music. You never even gave out the
goods. Not yet. I was about to big time.
I was about to demonstrate
the whole thing,
but you already did and I thank you for
it. Cause I don't think we're doing a,
also on Amazon you can get Jocko
white tea, which uh, you know,
there's been a lot of scientific studies
done and a lot of people have tried it.
We have witnesses.
You can absolutely dead lift 8,000 pounds,
including Jordan Peterson by the way.
Yeah.
He's now dead left and he's only dead
lifting 7,000 pounds before and this is
coming from him now he's dead
lifting 8,000 pounds, so that's good.
Jocko white tea.
There's some great reviews on there.
You might want to read those.
Uh,
we've got some books way the
warrior kid shows kids the path.
The next warrior kid book
is coming out April 28th
so you can let you know
when you can get that.
I don't know when you can right now,
but that's when it's coming out.
I'm done writing it,
just doing editing now.
And also there's the book we talked
about earlier, extreme ownership. Rip My,
me and my brother Leif Babin
and the new additions out.
Combat leadership for business in life.
There's a lot of lessons in
there you can learn from it.
I learned from it
also the discipline equals
freedom field manual.
And when you say that,
you got to say it like that
because sometimes people don't,
don't want to say field manual.
When someone pointed it out, I don't know.
They just say it was discipline. Yeah.
Discipline equals freedom field manual.
A guy who said today on social
media, on Twitter, he hit,
he hit it up and you said, hey, it's
a field manual. It's not a book you
don't read from cover to cover.
It's a field manual so you take it out
when you need it. Yeah. You refer to it.
You go through it. Maybe go through
a onetime, cause it's not long,
not a long read. This ain't about
face by Colonel David Hackworth.
You can probably read this in two hours,
three hours. Sure. Then
once you've read it,
you go back to it. Yeah. The field manual
teaching you how to get after
it mentally and physically.
The thoughts and actions that you can
take to get better opportune time bought
people. Got It for Christmas. Now
they're implementing new years.
Good
new years resolution.
Also a lot of people still asking for the
Audio version of the discipline equals
freedom field manual.
It is not on audible.
It is on iTunes, Amazon music,
Google play and other MP,
three broadcasting platforms.
That's where you can get it
if you need further implementation in
your business or your organization or your
team. Beyond the podcast and beyond
the books. We have echelon front,
which is our leadership consulting
company. It's me, Leif, Babin, JP Denelle,
Dave Burke,
email
info@echelonfrontdotcomorcheckoutthewebsiteechelonfront.com.
On top of that we have the muster.
Yeah,
the monster is a
leadership gathering. Yeah,
it's in Washington DC,
May 17th and 18th it is in San Francisco,
October 17th and 18th
come and get it.
You can register@extremeownership.com
and if you need to follow up with us with
questions or answers or
comments or just to cruise.
That's cool. We are actually
on the interwebs, Twitter,
Instagram
and FAC.
Echo is an echo.
Charles and I am at Jockowillink and
thank you for listening to the show and
thanks to those of you that are
listening that make this show possible.
Those of you in the armed services
that are out there on the front lines
worldwide,
keeping peace and protecting
our freedoms to police,
law enforcement, firefighters, paramedics,
and the other first responders.
Thanks for holding the line here at
home and keeping our families safe.
Thank you for your service
as well and to everyone.
Remember
that even now,
the clock is bringing closer,
closer to that moment.
So train hard and work hard and do
everything you can to be prepared.
So when that time does come,
you can step up
and get after it.
So until next time,
this is echo and Jocko.